GOOD MORNING WE WILL STARTS ARE
COMMITTEE HEARING TODAY BECAUSE
WE NEED TO MOVE ON WITH THIS
MORNING THIS IS OUR OUR FIRST
ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
NUMBER TWO ON EDUCATION FINANCE
RELATED TO OUR K..
TWELVE A BUDGETS --
TODAY WE'RE GOING TO HEAR IT
OVERVIEW --
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IN THE LA --
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S JANUARY --
BUDGET PROPOSALS RELATED TO K.
TWELVE EDUCATION AND EARLY AT
AND WILL ALSO TALK ABOUT OVERALL
PROP --
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING LEVELS --
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR A LITTLE BIT
LATER FROM OUR SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
THIS REPRESENTATIVE YES THERE
WERE AND WE'RE GONNA HEAR FROM
THE OFFICE OF THE OF THE SUPER
TEN THE PUBLIC EDUCATION --
BUT TODAY'S ISRAELI WE'LL GET
INTO THE ACTION ITEMS LATER IN
THE SPRING.
BUT OVERALL JUST FOCUSING ON THE
THE GOVERNOR'S BALL PROPOSAL WE
KNOW IT'S KIND OF A WORKLOAD
BUDGETS WITH THAT.
COLOR FOR LC A PFAFF SOME
OPPORTUNITIES TO LOOK AT SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING.
AND SOME RELIEF TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WITH THEIR PENSION
COSTS -- WE
KNOW BASED ON WHAT'S HAPPENING
ACROSS THE STATE IN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS INCLUDING.
RIGHT HERE IN MY BACKYARD WHERE
KIDS GO TO SCHOOL AND ONE OF MY
FAMILY MEMBERS INVOLVED WITH THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THAT -- YOU
KNOW SCHOOLS ARE HAVING A TOUGH
TIME AND SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
THIS YEAR THE ADEQUATE LET THING
FOR OUR SCHOOL TO GO TEACHER
[inaudible]
AND SO FOR TWO THAT TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
AS WELL AS THE HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT --
THIS SPRING --
WITH THAT WE WENT TO INVITE UP
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
LA JOH IN DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION. TO TALK ABOUT OUR
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY PROPOSAL
FROM THE GOVERNOR
[inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AARON
AND AREA DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
TODAY I'M GOING TO PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN OVERVIEW.
ON THE CALCULATION OF THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT MINIMUM
GUARANTEED ALONG WITH THE
SPENDING THAT'S PROPOSED WITH IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
A SPENDING PLAN.
SO FOR THE CALCULATION OF THE
GUARANTEE THE BUDGET PROPOSES
THE HIGHEST LEVEL OF FUNDING
EVER UNDER THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEEING.
AT EIGHTY POINT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS UP FROM SEVENTY SEVEN
POINT NINE BILLION IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN END UP FROM
FORTY SEVEN BILLION DURING THE
TROUGH OF THE RECESSION.
WITH CONTINUED REVENUE GROWTH
DURING THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY
FROM THE GREAT RECESSION TOTAL
GENERAL FUND REVENUES AT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET ARE ESTIMATED.
TO BE ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AN INCREASE OF FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS OVER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN LEVELS.
AT A TOTAL OF EIGHTY POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS THAT'S A PER
PEOPLE EXPENDITURE FROM PROP.
NINETY EIGHT OF JUST OVER TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AN INCREASE OF
FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
DOLLARS PER PEOPLE OVER EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN LEVELS.
AS NOTED --
EXCUSE ME I HAVE.
A COUPLE OF HAND OUTS HERE ONE
HAND UP IF.
GIVEN TO THEM.
SORRY ABOUT THAT --
AND THEN.
SO I WAS GOING TO REFER TO THE
HAND OUT THAT'S WHAT REMINDED ME --
IN FIGURE FIVE OF THE HAND OUT
ON THE ON THE BACK SIDE OF THE
PAGE.
ARE YOU CAN SEE THAT FUNDED
LEVELS IN.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN DECLINE FROM THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT LEVELS BY
ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
AND FIVE HUNDRED AND TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS RESPECTIVELY.
DUE LARGELY TO LOWER THAN
ANTICIPATED AVERAGE DAILY
ATTENDANCE AND YEAR OVER YEAR
DECLINE IN GENERAL FUND REVENUE
GROWTH FROM SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN COMPARED AGAIN
TO THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET
ACT.
WELL GENERAL FUND REVENUES ARE
INCREASED ACROSS THE BUDGET
WINDOW COMPARED TO THE BUDGET
ACT THE YEAR OVER YEAR REVENUE
INCREASE OF TWO POINT NINE
BILLION DOLLARS AND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN COMPARED TO TWO AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS.
AS WE GO TO EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
HAS THE EFFECT OF LIMITING
GROWTH IN THE GUARANTEED IN THE
CURRENT YEAR.
AS OPPOSED TO IF REVENUES HAD
INCREASED BY MORE THAN TWO POINT
NINE IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WE ANTICIPATE
THAT ANY GROWTH IN REVENUES IN
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN BEYOND
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS WOULD NOT RESULT
IN AN INCREASE TO THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
IN NINETEEN NINETEEN AS WE WOULD
SWITCH TO ATTEST TO WHERE THE
THE INFLATION ADJUSTMENT THAT IS
APPLIED TO THE GUARANTEES ON A
FUNCTION OF PER CAPITA PERSONAL
INCOME AND NOT GENERAL FUND
REVENUES THEREFORE ANY DECREASE
IN REVENUES IN.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN WHAT ALSO SEE
PROP NINETY EIGHT LOSE ABOUT
FIFTY FIVE CENTS ON THE DOLLAR
FOR EVERY DOLLAR IN LOST
REVENUES.
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY FOR
THE REVENUE INCREASES OR
DECREASES AT THE MAY REVISION.
WHAT IMPACT THE GUARANTEE BY
ABOUT FORTY CENTS ON THE DOLLAR
AS WE ARE EXPECTING TO BE AN A
TEST ONE GEAR --
ALSO AT THE MAY REVISION EVEN
WITH POTENTIAL OTHER FACTOR
CHANGES.
BECAUSE THERE'S NO LONGER ANY
OUTSTANDING MAINTENANCE FACTOR
BALANCE AS OUR HOUSE OFTEN BEEN
IN PREVIOUS BUDGETS.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT WILL
LIKELY NOT BE A SENSITIVE TO
CHANGES PARTICULARLY INCREASES
IN GENERAL FUND REVENUES AS IT
HAS BEEN IN RECENT YEARS WITH
THE NON PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND SIDE
OF THE BUDGET THIS TIME STANDING
TO GAIN PROPORTIONATELY MORE
FROM REVENUE INCREASES THAN IT
HAS IN PREVIOUS BUDGETS.
ADDITIONALLY THE BUDGET MAKES
THE FINAL PAYMENT TOWARDS
OUTSTANDING SETTLE IT BALANCES --
TO PRIOR FISCAL YEARS.
OF SIX HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SO.
K. FOURTEEN EDUCATION WILL NOT
EXPERIENCE A REDUCTION IN PRIOR
OR CURRENT YEAR APPROPRIATIONS
DESPITE DECLINES IN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AMOUNTS BECAUSE ONE WE
ARE MAINTAINING.
A FORTY FOUR MILLION DOLLAR OVER
APPROPRIATIONS TO THE
PROPOSITION NINETY MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND TWO WE ARE STE USING SETTLE
UP PAYMENTS TO OFFSET.
OTHERWISE UNFUNDED EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN OBLIGATIONS WHICH I'LL
DISCUSS IN A MOMENT AS WELL.
OUT SOME OF OUR MAJOR K. TWELVE
SPENDING PROPOSALS WHICH YOU CAN
ALSO SEE ON THAT HAND OUT.
OUR IN EARLY EDUCATION THE
BUDGET SHOULD PROPOSES TO SHIFT
TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS OF PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
PART A PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS A NON
LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES. TO
NON PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND. TO ALLOW FOR NON LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCY PROVIDERS TO
DRAW DOWN FULL DAY FOR YOUR
REIMBURSEMENT FROM A SINGLE
FUNDING SOURCE.
AND TO PROVIDE THEM WITH
FLEXIBILITY TO BEING BETTER USE
OF THEIR CONTRACT FUNDING.
EN EL CFF THE BUDGET BUILDS ON
PREVIOUS IS A INVESTMENTS SINCE
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOURTEEN INTO
THE LC A PFAFF WITH AN
ADDITIONAL TWO BILLION DOLLARS
AS THE CHAIR NOTED.
IN --
NINETEEN TWENTY AS A COLA TO THE
TARGET FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS BRINGING THE
TOTAL OF INCREASE FUNDING SINCE
THE ENACTMENT OF ELSE ABOUT. TO
JUST OVER TWENTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AND THE TOTAL FOR
NINETEEN TWENTY THAT'S BUDGET
FOR THE ENTIRE PROGRAM.
JUST OVER SIXTY THREE BILLION
DOLLARS AS SHOWN IN FIGURE FOR
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO USE APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WORTH OF OUTSTANDING
SETTLE AT PAYMENTS. TO FIND OUT
IF OF AN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN
ORDER TO AVOID HAVING TO MAKE
CURRENT YOUR CUTS TO SCHOOLS AS
A RESULT OF THE MINIMUM YEAR.
MINIMUM GUARANTEE DECREASING AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION THE BUDGET INCLUDES A
SPECIAL EDUCATION PROPOSAL USING
BOTH ON GOING AT ONE TIME PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDS. THREE
HUNDRED NINETY MILLION OF WHICH
ARE.
ONGOING AND A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY EIGHT MILLION OF WHICH
ARE [inaudible] ONE TIME.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT EXPANDED SPECIAL
EDUCATION SERVICES AND SCHOOL
READINESS SUPPORTS AT LOCAL
EDUCATION AGENCIES WITH HIGH
PERCENTAGES OF BOTH STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES AND UNDEFEATED
PUPILS.
WHO ARE LOW INCOME FOSTER YOUTH
ARE ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS?
THE BUDGET PROVIDES AN
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
CALL AND GROWTH ADJUSTMENTS FOR
OTHER KEY TO A PROBLEM AT
PROGRAMS.
AND FOR THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THE BUDGET PROVIDES A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT OF TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND THE
SECOND YEAR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISE. TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS FOR ENROLLMENT
GROWTH EIGHTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
FOR ADULT EDUCATION COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT. TEN POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS AS WELL FOR
FINANCIAL AID AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR LEGAL SERVICES FOR A
DOCUMENT UNDOCUMENTED AND
IMMIGRANT STUDENTS.
SOME OF THE MAJOR K. FOURTEEN
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND SPENDING THAT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
ARE LISTED ON FIGURE.
THREE ON THE HAND OUT.
AND IN THERE I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THERE'S A THREE
BILLION DOLLAR CAL STIRS REALLY
FOR EMPLOYERS A PROPOSAL UNDER
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
WE ARE PROPOSING TO SPEND
APPROXIMATELY A TOTAL OF SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS BEING NINETEEN
TWENTY AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE
REDUCING EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS
IN EACH OF THOSE YEARS BY AN
ESTIMATED 1%.
THE REMAINING APPROXIMATELY TWO
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLARS WILL
GO TOWARDS PAYING DOWN THE LONG
TERM UNFUNDED LIABILITY OWED BY
EMPLOYERS ESTIMATED TO EQUAL
ABOUT A FIVE POINT 5% REDUCTION
IN FUTURE YEAR.
CONTRIBUTION RATES BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR A
TOTAL OF ESTIMATED SAVINGS OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS THROUGH TWENTY FORTY SIX
THE LIFE OF THE CULTURES FUNDING
PLAN.
WELL ALL THE FOLLOWING PROPSALS
WILL BE DISCUSSED IN MORE DETAIL
AT A LATER HEARING ALSO WANTED
TO HIGHLIGHT A SERIES OF
STRATEGIC EARLY LEARNING
INVESTMENTS.
A TOTAL ABOUT TWO POINT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS IN SUPPORT OF
THE WHOLE CHILD THROUGH
COLLABORATION ACROSS MULTIPLE
SYSTEMS SUCH AS HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES HIGHER EDUCATION AND
LABOR.
SPECIFICALLY THE BUDGET PROPOSES
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ONE TIME NON PROBLEM
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO TO
CONTINUED. FOR CONTINUED NEW
CONSTRUCTION OR RETROFITTING
EXISTING FACILITIES FOR FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN PROGRAMS.
OR TO FUND OTHER ACTIVITIES TO
REDUCE VERY PROVIDE FULL DAY
KINDERGARTEN. FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO BOTH EXPAND SUBSIDIZED
CHILDCARE FACILITIES IN THE
STATE.
AND MAKE A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN THE EDUCATION OF
THE CHILD CARE WORK FORCE. TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF CARE AND
MOVE CHILD CARE PROFESSIONALS
ALONG THE EARLY EDUCATION.
CHILD CARE PROFESSIONAL
CONTINUUM.
AN ADDITIONAL HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
FULL DAY FULL YEAR.
ACCESS TO SEATS RESPECTFULLY
SCHOOL TO ALL ELIGIBLE LOW
INCOME FOR URALS.
AND THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES
INCREASES TO CAO WORKS CAL GRANT
ACCESS HOME VISITING AMONG OTHER
PROGRAMS [inaudible]
LASTLY.
THE BUDGET PROPOSES TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO PLAN AND BEGIN
DEVELOPMENT OF A LONGITUDINAL
DATA SYSTEM THAT WILL WORK TO
WEAVE TOGETHER STUDENT DATA
ACROSS EARLY EDUCATION K. TWELVE
HIGHER EDUCATION.
WORKFORCE AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SYSTEMS.
WITH THAT I WILL CONCLUDE MY
COMMENTS AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY THANK YOU WILL --
PROCEED WITH THEIR LA --
AND THEN DEPARTMENT OF ADD
BEFORE WE A HAVE QUESTIONS BUT
LET'S JUST TAKE THE ROLL OVER --
HERE REAL QUICK [inaudible]
MCCARTY HERE [inaudible]
PRO.
GALLAGHER.
LOW MOAN.
ANNA YOUR FIRST TO CHEER
O'DONNELL.
THANK YOU I AM.
THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS KENNETH
COUPON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT THAT THE
SERGEANT DISTRIBUTED EARLIER.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION GIVE
YOU A GOOD OVERVIEW OF THE MAJOR
MOVING PIECES IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET.
AND I THINK --
IRAN'S PRESENTATIONS ALSO A
TIMELY REMINDER THAT WILL NEARLY
A DOZEN INPUTS AFFECT THE
CALCULATION OF THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
THE THREE MOST IMPORTANT IN THIS
YEAR AND MOST OTHER YEAR IS ARE
THE YEAR OVER YEAR CHANGES IN
GENERAL FUND REVENUE.
GROWTH IN THE STATE ECONOMY AND
CHANGES IN STUDENT ATTENDANCE.
AS A TURNING TO PAGE ONE OF OUR
HAND OUT AS N PREVIOUS YEARS
THE MINIMUM GUARANTEE IN THE
CURRENT YEAR HAS MOVED QUITE A
BIT.
SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF THE STATE
BUDGET HAS DROPPED SINCE LAST
JUNE A SCHOOL FUNDING RIGHT NOW
IS FOUR HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION ABOVE THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE.
AND AS YOU HEARD EARLIER THEY
ADMINISTRATION AS A PROPOSAL TO
RE CLASSIFY THAT FUNDING ABOUT
THE GUARANTEE.
AS A PAYMENT TOWARD SOME PRIOR
FISCAL YEAR IS.
AND THAT SIGNIFICANT BOTH
BECAUSE IT AVOID THIS --
MID YEAR CUTS AND PAYMENT
DEFERRALS SO IT'S UP MORE
STABILITY AND PREDICTABILITY FOR
SCHOOLS.
IT ALSO KEEPS THAT FUNDING FROM
BECOMING PART OF THE BASIS FOR
CALCULATING NEXT YEAR'S
GUARANTEE SO IT GIVES YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBILITY AND
SUBSEQUENT BUDGETS.
I TURNING TO PAGE TWO OF OUR
HAND OUT AS YOU FOR THE
MINISTRATION SAY --
THE GUARANTEE UNDER THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WOULD GROW
THREE POINT 6% IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AND
YOU PROBABLY I RECOGNIZE THAT AS
BEING A BIT LOWER THAN WHAT.
WE'VE SEEN IN SOME PREVIOUS YEAR
IS A LOT OF THAT PREVIOUS GROWTH
HAD TO DO WITH THIS
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENT FOR
THE STATE TO A STORY SCHOOL
FUNDING FOR INCREASES IT DIDN'T
PROVIDE DURING THE RECESSION
YEARS.
AND THE STATE AS OF LAST YEAR
HAS NO FINISHED MAKING THOSE
RESTORATION PAYMENTS AND SO
SCHOOL FUNDING IS LIKELY TO GROW.
MORE SLOWLY MOVING FORWARD.
EVEN IF WE HAVE A VERY STRONG
ECONOMY LIKE THE ONE RIGHT NOW.
I THINK THIS YEAR'S BUDGET GIVES
YOU A GOOD FLAVOR OF WHAT THAT.
KIND OF NEW GROWTH WILL LOOK
LIKE I WITH GROWTH MORE IN THE
RANGE OF 324% COMPARED WITH SIX
OR 7% IN PREVIOUS YEARS.
THE ADMINISTRATION ALSO WAS
UPDATED ASSESSMENT OF LOCAL
PROPERTY TAX REVENUE I WE CAN
COVER THAT IN MORE DETAIL IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED --
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT WE
THINK THE ADMINISTRATION'S
ESTIMATES OF PROPERTY TAX
REVENUE I REASONABLE ACROSS THE
ENTIRE THREE YEAR BUDGET PERIOD
OF THEIR OUR ESTIMATES --
THE IN BELOW ARE IS STILL QUITE
CLOSE MUCH CLOSER EVEN THAN IN
SOME PREVIOUS YEARS.
TURNING TO PAGE THREE OF THIS IS
LARGELY JUST A RECAP OF ALL OF
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT PROPOSALS IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET.
I WON'T COVER ANY OF THESE RIGHT
NOW BECAUSE I THINK OF YOU ALL
OF THEM AND SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS.
WHAT I THINK IS THE MOST
STRIKING FEATURE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OVERALL PACKAGE IS
JUST HOW MUCH OF THE NEW
SPENDING IS DEDICATED TO
COVERING THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT --
WE ESTIMATE THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS TWO POINT NINE BILLION IN
NET NEW SPENDING.
ACROSS SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND OF THAT AMOUNT TWO
AND A HALF BILLION IS DEDICATED
TO COVERING A THREE AND A HALF
HALF PERCENT COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT.
SO THAT REALLY MAKES THIS FOR A
OF A STRAIGHT FORWARD BUDGET.
TEN WITH MUCH FEWER NEW
PROPOSALS THAT YOU'VE SEEN IN
SOME PRIOR YEARS.
TURNING TO PAGE FOR I THINK A
LITTLE HISTORICAL REVIEW MIGHT
HELP BUT THE BUDGET IN CONTEXT.
UNDER THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
SCHOOL FUNDING WOULD BE TWELVE
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN DOLLARS
PER PUPIL IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AN
INCREASE OF THREE POINT 8% OVER
THE REVISED TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN LEVEL.
DUE IN LARGE PART TO A VERY LONG
ECONOMIC EXPANSION THIS IS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF FUNDING THE
STATE HAS EVER PROVIDED.
ADJUSTED FOR INFLATION A SCHOOL
FUNDING IS FIVE HUNDRED PER
STUDENT ABOVE THE PREVIOUS PEAK
IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO THOUSAND ONE
AND ABOUT TWELVE HUNDRED ABOVE
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVEN EIGHT A
PREVIOUS SESSION LEVEL.
A TURNING TO PAGE FIVE WE
SOMETIMES LOOK BEYOND OUR OWN
BORDERS TO SEE HOW CALIFORNIA
EDUCATION SPENDING COMPARES WITH
OTHER STATES.
THIS IS ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT OF A
DIFFICULT COMPARISON BECAUSE
YOU'RE.
LOOKING AT NOT JUST VERY
DECISIONS BUT ALSO THE DECISION
STATE YOUR IS AFFECTING THOSE
RANKINGS.
ARE THE MOST AUTHORITATIVE
SOURCE FOR SPENDING COMPARISONS
COMES FROM THE US CENSUS BUREAU.
THE MAIN DRAWBACK OF THEIR DATA
IS THAT IT TENDS TO LAKE A
COUPLE YEARS AND SO ANY TIME
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT RANKINGS
WERE ALWAYS A LITTLE BIT BEHIND
THE TIMES.
WE DO REALIZE THAT SOME OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS SOMETIMES PRODUCE
THEIR OWN SPENDING RANKINGS --
BUT WOULDN'T LEAVE EXAMINE THOSE
ESTIMATES WE TEND TO FIND THEM
LESS RELIABLE IN A LITTLE BIT
LESS CONSISTENT THAN WHAT THE
CENSUS BUREAU PUTS FORWARD.
SO AS A FIFTEEN SIXTEEN LATEST
YEAR WE HAVEN'T LEADERSHIP WE
HAVE DATA CALIFORNIA RANKS
TWENTY THIRD IN PER PUPIL
SPENDING AMONG THE FIFTY STATES
AND DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA.
SOME ORGANIZATIONS THOUGH TRY TO
GO FURTHER AND TRY TO ADJUST
THAT CENSUS BUREAU DATA FOR THE
REGIONAL VARIATION THAT WE SEE
IN COST ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
AND AS YOU ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS RELATIVELY HIGH COST STATE.
THINGS TEND TO COST MORE HERE WE
TEND TO HAVE HIGHER WAGES AND SO
THOSE ADJUSTMENTS TEND TO RESULT
IN CALIFORNIA DROPPING.
THAT WE DON'T CURRENTLY HAVE
RELIABLE ACOSTA JUST THE DATA --
FOR TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
BUT OUR BEST ESTIMATE IS THAT
ONCE THAT DATA DO BECOME
AVAILABLE IN THE COMING MONTHS
CALIFORNIA WILL PROBABLY RANK IN
THE MID THIRTIES ON THAT COST
ADJUSTED DATA.
I THINK THE STATE COMPARISONS
ARE ALSO REMINDER OF JUST HOW
VOLATILE I SPENDING IS COMPARED
TO OTHER STATES.
FROM 200-078-22000 TEN ELEVEN
SCHOOL SPENDING IN CALIFORNIA
DROPPED MORE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE AND FROM 200-010-1122
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IT GREW
FASTER THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
SO SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TO
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO A LOT MORE
SWINGSAND SPENDING COMPARED TO
SOME OTHER STATES.
AT THE TURNING TO PAGE SIX I'D
LIKE TO SHIFT FROM A LOOK BACK
TO LOOK AHEAD AND WHAT THE MAY
REVISION MIGHT HOLD IN STORE FOR
YOU.
ON BALANCE WE THINK THERE'S A
BIT MORE DOWNSIDE AN UPSIDE THIS
YEAR AS PART AS POSSIBLE CHANGES
IN THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
BUDGET.
A PART OF THAT STORY HAS TO DO
WITH REVENUE AS I THINK MOST OF
YOU KNOW THE STOCK MARKET DROPS
NOTABLY AT THE END OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AND THAT DROP HAPPENED
AFTER THE POINT WITH THE
pADMINISTRATION TYPICALLY LOCKS
DOWN ITS ECONOMIC ASSUMPTIONS.
A STOCK MARKET HAS MADE UP A LOT
OF GROUND SINCE THEN BUT WE
STILL THINK WE COULD SEE SOME
LOWER REVENUE PARTICULARLY IN
THE CURRENT YEAR.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN SOME SIGNS THAT
THE ECONOMY MIGHT BE SLOWING A
TOUCH.
SOME EXAMPLES INCLUDE WE'VE HAD
A SMALL UPTICK IN UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS RECENTLY AND AS WELL AS A
SMALL DOWN TAKEN HOME SALES.
AND THAT'S SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE IS SENSITIVE TO OUR
REVENUE ESTIMATES. FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION STATE EARLIER FOR
EACH DOLLAR BUT FIFTY FIVE CENTS
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN AND ABOUT FORTY CENTS
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN TWENTY THE
OTHER PART OF THE STORY IS THAT
WE THINK THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGETING EXCLUDE SOME COSTS
THAT ARE LIKELY TO MATERIALIZE
IN THE COMING MONTHS.
THE BIGGEST ISSUE IS RELATED TO
A KIND OF A ONE TIME PROPERTY
TAX BACK FILL IN SAN FRANCISCO.
IT'S REALLY A KIND OF A
CORRECTION OF SOME PREVIOUS
PROPERTY TAX CALCULATIONS AND
FROM PRIOR YEARS.
WE ALSO THINK THAT SOME OF YOUR
FORMULA DRIVEN SPENDING PUTTING
SPENDING AND COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
IT'S LIKELY TO BE A BIT HIGHER
THAN THE ADMINISTRATION
ESTIMATES.
YOU'LL HEAR MORE ABOUT ALL OF
THESE ISSUES AND SUBSEQUENT
HEARINGS BUT IN TOTAL ACROSS ALL
OF THE ISSUES YOU'VE IDENTIFIED.
WE THINK THOSE X. ADDITIONAL
COSTS MIGHT BE IN THE RANGE OF A
FEW HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE BETWEEN A LOWER MINIMUM
GUARANTEE AND HIGHER COSTS WE
THINK YOU'RE PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT BUDGET COULD BE TIGHTER BY
MAY.
I TURNING TO PAGE SEVEN WE THINK
YOU HAVE A COUPLE OPTIONS TO
THINK ABOUT TO BEGIN PREPARING
FOR THOSE POTENTIAL CHANGES. ONE
IS TO USE THE COMING MONTHS TO
IDENTIFY PROPOSALS THAT YOU
MIGHT BE WILLING TO REJECT OR
PERHAPS REDUCE OF REVENUE COMES
IN LOWER THAN ANTICIPATED.
IF YOU WOULD IDENTIFY SOME OF
THOSE THINGS NOW THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE.
THE MAJOR REVISION --
CHANGES FOR YOU A LITTLE BIT
EASIER.
BUT WE ALSO THINK YOU SHOULD
CONSIDER BUILDING.
I SING SOME OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED ONGOING SPENDING I WITH
ONE TIME INITIATIVES RIGHT NOW
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET HAS
VIRTUALLY NO.
SPENDING BUILT INTO THE NINETEEN
TWENTY BUDGET THAT'S ONE TIME.
AND THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A
RISKIER APPROACH COMPARED TO
SOME PREVIOUS YEAR IT'S BECAUSE
THE FUNDING DROPS EITHER NOW OR
PERHAPS IN A YEAR.
YOU HAVE FEWER THINGS THAT YOU
CAN REDUCE WITHOUT.
WE THINK THAT BUILDING IN A
LITTLE BIT MORE ONE TIME FUNDING
WOULD --
POSITION YOU BETTER TO ADDRESS
ANY DROPS THAT HAPPENED BY NAME.
ABOUT SO TURNING TO PAGE EIGHT
TELL JUST ADDRESS ONE FINAL
COMPONENT OF THE PROPOSITION
NINETY PACKAGE.
AT WHICH IS HOW THE STATE
ADDRESSES CHANGES IN THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE THAT OCCUR AFTER THE
YEAR IS OVER.
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT IS
REALLY KIND OF A UNIQUE --
PART OF STATE BUDGET AND NETWORK
IT'S NOT EVEN FINAL ONCE THE
YEAR AND WE HAVE TO WAIT ANOTHER
NINE MONTHS AFTER THE END OF THE
YEAR AT LEAST TO GET FINAL DATA --
THOSE CHANGES HAPPENING AFTER
THE YEAR IS OVER CAN BE IN THE
RANGE OF A FEW OF TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO IN SOME
CASES LOW HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS.
AT TRADITIONALLY WHEN THE
GUARANTEE IS HIGHER THAN THE
PREVIOUS ESTIMATE THE STATE
MAKES A ONE TIME PAYMENT TO
SETTLE UP TO THAT HIGHER FUNDING
LEVEL.
AND WITH A MINIMUM GUARANTEE IS
BELOW THE PREVIOUS ESTIMATE THE
STATE TENDS TO REDUCE SCHOOL
FUNDING TO THE LOWER LEVEL.
AND THE STATE USUALLY MAKES THAT
REDUCTION BY CLASSIFYING SOME
FUNDING ABOUT THE GUARANTEE IS
BEING RELATED TO A PRIOR FISCAL
YEAR A YEAR WHERE IT HASN'T
ALREADY MET THE GUARANTEE --
THAT APPROACH LET'S SCHOOLS KEEP
THE FUNDING THEY WERE ALREADY
PLANNING TO RECEIVE --
BUT IT RECOGNIZES THE LOWER BASE
FOR CALCULATING HE MINIMUM
GUARANTEED MOVING FORWARD AND
THE FACT THAT I'M DESCRIBING IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS PROPOSED FOR THE EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR.
A LAST YEAR'S BUDGET CREATED A
NEW TRUCK PROCESS TO TRY TO
AUTOMATE THOSE UPWARD AND
DOWNWARD ADJUSTMENTS.
AT THIS WAS DESIGNED TO MAKE
CHANGES IN THE GUARANTEE AND THE
ASSOCIATED FUNDING ADJUSTMENTS A
LITTLE BIT MORE PREDICTABLE A
LITTLE BIT LESS DISRUPTIVE FOR
BOTH SCHOOLS AND THE STATE.
A TURNING TO PAGE NINE THE
GOVERNOR HAS TO PROPOSALS
RELATED TO DROPS.
HE'S PROPOSING TO ELIMINATE THE
AUTOMATIC PROCESS COULD LAST
YEAR.
AND TO PROHIBIT THE STATE FOR
MAKING GET WELL FUNDING IN THE
PRIOR YEAR WILL STILL REQUIRE AN
UPWARD ADJUSTMENTS --
WE THINK THAT --
IF YOU ADOPT THOSE PROPOSALS YOU
WOULD ESSENTIALLY BE COMMITTING
TO HAVING ANY DROPS IN STATE
REVENUE.
IN THE PRIOR YEAR FALL ENTIRELY
ON THE NONPROFIT THIS NINETY
EIGHT SIDE OF THE BUDGET.
AND WE THINK THAT'S GOING TO
MAKE YOUR OVERALL BUDGET MORE
DIFFICULT TO BALANCE.
A BOTH IN THE CURRENT YEAR AND
POTENTIALLY IN SUBSEQUENT YEARS
TO AND THAT'S BECAUSE FUNDING
ABOVE THE GUARANTEE AND ONE YEAR
BECOMES PART OF THAT BASE FOR
CALCULATING THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE THE NEXT YEAR.
AND SO FOR BOTH OF THOSE REASONS
WE RECOMMEND YOU REJECT THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS AND
PRESERVE YOUR FLEXIBILITY.
TO FIND OUT THE GUARANTEE OR
SOME OTHER LEVEL IF THAT'S WHAT
YOU CHOOSE.
THAT'S THE TURNING TO PAGE TEN
I'D LIKE TO TRANSITION TO THE
OTHER HALF OF YOUR AGENDA.
EVERYTHING I JUST TOLD YOU
RELATED TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET --
BUT THE NEXT FEW PAGES COVER
YOUR EARLY EDUCATION BUDGET THIS
YEAR.
AND UNLIKE WHAT I JUST TOLD YOU
THIS PART OF YOUR BUDGET IS
ALMOST ENTIRELY OUTSIDE OF
PROPOSITION.
NINETY EIGHT SO THE CHART ON
PAGE TEN JUST LIST THE PROPOSALS
IN THIS YEAR'S EARLY EDUCATION --
BUDGET AS IN PREVIOUS YEARS IT'S
A MIX OF ONE TIME INITIATIVES
AND NEW ON GOING COMMITMENTS.
TURNING TO PAGE ELEVEN THE
LARGEST PROPOSAL IS SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
KINDERGARTEN FACILITY GRANTS.
AND THIS BUILDS UPON SOME
FUNDING YOU ALLOCATED THIS
COURAGE DISTRICTS TO CONVERT
THEIR PART TAKEN THE GARDEN
PROGRAMS TO FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
IN REVIEWING THE APPLICATIONS
THAT THE STATE'S RECEIVED SO FAR --
WE'VE CONCLUDED THAT THE CLINTON
GRANTS DON'T SEEM TO BE
ADVANCING YOUR CORE OBJECTIVE
MOST OF THE APPLICANTS APPLYING
FOR THIS FUNDING ARE ARE ALREADY
RUNNING FULL DAY PROGRAMS ARE
NOT APPLYING TO CONVERT TO RUN
MORE.
MORE OF THOSE PROGRAMS.
AND SO IN SUBSEQUENT HEARINGS
YOU'LL HEAR US LAY OUT SOME
ALTERNATIVES.
THAT COULD PROVIDE STRONGER
INCENTIVES FOR FULL DAY PROGRAMS
AT A LOWER COST IN THE MEANTIME
WE RECOMMEND YOU HOLD OFF AND
NOT PROVIDE THE PROPOSED SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
ADDITIONAL CAN GUARDED GRANTS AT
THIS POINT.
AND SO WITH THAT LET ME TURN
THINGS OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE TO
TAKE US THROUGH THE FINAL --
PARTS OF OUR HAND OUT.
GOOD MORNING SERRA CORTEZ WITH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
AND I'LL I WILL DISCUSS THE
REMAINDER OF PAGE ELEVEN OF YOUR
HAND OUT WHICH IS CHILD CARE AND
OUR ASSESSMENT AND
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR CHILD CARE
AND PRESCHOOL PROGRAMS.
SO ON THE SECOND BOLD ITEM OF
PAGE --
ELEVEN IS WITH REGARDS TO THE
ONE TIMEFUNDING THE GOVERNOR
PROPOSES FOR WORK FORCE AND
FACILITY PURPOSE SAYS.
I'M IN WE GIVEN THE LACK OF DATA --
AVAILABLE ON WORKFORCE AND
FACILITY ISSUES WE THINK MAKING
OF PRIORITIZING A ONE TIME CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL FUNDING IN
THIS AREA IS CHALLENGING ON THE
GOOD NEWS IS THAT SOME KEY
INFORMATION IS COMING IN THE
NEXT YEAR OR TWO AND THERE COULD
ALSO BE SOME ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
MAY WANT --
TO HAVE BEFORE IMPLEMENTING A
TARGET ISSUES WITH HER --
IN AND IN SPECIFIC REGIONS.
A WE RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATOR
THE LEGISLATURE SATISFIED SOME
OF THE FUNDING AND ALLOCATED IN
FUTURE YEARS AS IT GETS BETTER
INFORMATION.
UNDER THE THIRD BULLET HERE IS
WITH REGARDS TO THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION --
THE GOVERNOR ADDS TEN THOUSANDS
PRESCHOOL SLOTS IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND WE THINK THIS --
EXPANSION IS QUITE AMBITIOUS --
THERE'S MANY LOGISTICAL
CHALLENGES FROM STATE
ADMINISTRATION AND ON THE
PROVIDER LEVEL --
ON THAT --
THAT AND WE SUGGESTS A SLOWER
RAMP UP TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
LOGISTICAL CHALLENGES.
AND THE LAST THE FINAL BULLET
HERE IS WITH REGARDS TO
ELIMINATING THE WORK REQUIREMENT
FOR FULL DAY STATE PRESCHOOL SO
UNDER CURRENT LAW PART A STEEPER
SCHOOL DOESN'T HAVE A WORK
REQUIREMENT AND FULL DAY STATE
PRESCHOOL DOES --
WE THINK THAT THIS ELIMINATING
THIS REQUIREMENT COULD HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES --
THAT.
AND AND HERE'S TO SPECIFIC
CONSEQUENCES THAT WE HIGHLIGHT
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL COULD
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASE THE COST
OF THE PROGRAM --
AS A FULL DAY COST A FULL DAY
SLOT COSTS OVER TO OF OVER TWO
TIMES THE COST OF A PART DAIS
THOUGHT --
AND ABSENT ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
THE PROGRAM COULD RESULT IN
FEWER OVERALL CHILDREN AS WELL
AS FEWER CHILDREN FROM WORKING
FAMILIES BEING SERVED UP WITH WE
RECOMMEND REJECTING --
ELIMINATING THE WORK REQUIREMENT
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS --
NICK SCHWEITZER DEPUTY
SUPERINTENDENT DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SO OUR OUR CHIEF
DEPUTY --
LUPITA CORTEZ OUT CLOUT WILL BE
HERE LATER AND TALK A BIT ABOUT
THE THAT SUPERMAN'S PRIORITIES --
FOR NEXT YEAR AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION SO I'M GONNA
FOCUS MORE ON JUST SORT OF WHAT
THE THE KEY POINTS WE WE SEE IN
THE GOV.
SO WE'RE VERY PLEASED OVERALL
AND IN THE STRONG INVESTMENTS
PROPOSED PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR FOR EDUCATION THE
PLEASE THAT HE'S.
DOING WE ARE MAKING THESE
INVESTMENTS BOTH K. TWELVE AN
EARLY ED IN A WAY THAT'S PRUDENT
AND SUSTAINABLE --
AND OVERALL THAT HE'S YO FOCUSES
BUDGET ON THE HELPING%
CALIFORNIANS WHO WHO.
NEED IT MOST --
IN PARTICULAR THE THE AREA OF K. --
TWELVE FULLY FUNDING THE L. C.
F. F. FORMULA AND THE COAL IS IS
VERY IMPORTANT --
BREED NERO IS WELL AS THE
INVESTMENTS IN IN --
SPECIAL EDUCATION --
AND THEN THE NOT NOT TO BE --
DISCOUNTED CHARLIE THE THERE IS
A INVESTMENTS TO REDUCE DOORS
COSTS AND ALSO HIS IS --
DESIRE TO TO SELL --
COSTS THAT THAT LOCAL DISTRICTS
EXPERIENCE THAT DETRACT FROM
WHAT INVESTMENTS THEY CAN MAKE
IN IN THEIR EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM
SO THOSE THOSE ARE AS CRITICAL
AS ANY -- ON
THE EARLY EDUCATION SIDE.
HERE AGAIN THE THE FOCUS ON THE
WHOLE CHILD JUST IN THE BUDGET
IN GENERAL NOT JUST INVESTMENTS
IN.
EARLY ED BUT ALSO IN THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SIDE OF THE
BUDGET ARE VERY IMPORTANT FOR
SUPPORTING --
THE AGE EDUCATIONAL PAYMENT IN
IN THE EARLY YEARS AND AND
THROUGHOUT --
CHILD'S --
SCHOOL EXPERIENCE CERTAINLY VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THE PRE SCHOOL
EXPANSION.
AND THE UNDERLYING ANY EXPANSION
IN EARLY IT HAS TO BE SYSTEMS
BUILDING SO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INVESTMENTS IN FACILITIES AND
AND WORKFORCE TRAINING FOR FOR
EIJI EARLY EDUCATION PROVIDERS --
SO YOU KNOW WE CERTAINLY AGREE
THAT ALL THESE PARTIES ARE ARE
NECESSARY TO THE MORE CHILDREN
CAN GET HEALTHY START THAT
PREPARES THEM FOR HIGHER READ
AND FOR THE WORK FORCE. TO LOOK --
FOR AND ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN AND
BUILDING UPON THESE PROPOSALS.
OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THROW A
INCREASING THE RESOURCES THAT.
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITIES HAVE TO
TO SUPPORT OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
CHILDREN THANK YOU.
OKAY ENTERTAIN QUESTIONS NOW
FROM OUR SISTER DONNA.
YES SO THIS QUESTION THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATIONS VERY
THOROUGH YEAH THIS QUESTIONS
REALLY FOR ANYBODY YOU MAY NOT
HAVE IT OFF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD
NOT UNDERSTAND WHY.
BUT THIS IS JUST DO WE HAVE ANY
DATA RELATIVE TO THE PER STUDENT
EXPENDITURES TO REGARD TO
SPECIAL ED.
NONE OF THE TOP OF YOUR HEAD I
IMAGINE NOT OFF THE TOP OF OUR
HEAD WE CAN GET THAT TO YOU ARE
HI I HAD THE DATA DO SO A PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEAR IS THE NUMBER OF
STUDENTS IDENTIFIED WITH
DISABILITIES.
HOVERED JUST BELOW 11% FOR A
VERY LONG TIME FOR DECADES AND
IT'S STARTED ACCELERATING ABOUT
SEVEN OR EIGHT YEARS AGO AND
IT'S BEEN GROWING AT A MUCH
FASTER THAN INFLATION THE PAST
COUPLE YEARS.
METICULOUS EARLY THE COSTS HAVE
BEEN GOING UP BECAUSE MANY OF
THE STUDENTS NEWLY IDENTIFIED
WITH DISABILITIES ARE IN SORT OF
HIGH COST AREAS THINGS LIKE
AUTISM.
AND SO THAT'S BEEN KIND OF A
SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURE FOR
DISTRICTS AS ACCOMMODATING THOSE
HIGHER SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS.
YEAH IT HAS AN IMPACT ON THEM.
ON THE MONEY SPENT ON NON
SPECIAL ED STUDENTS TO THANK YOU
KNOW JUST THIS WILL DO THIS
PRIME MORE OF A COMMENT THAN A
QUESTION BUT I JUST KIND OF
WORRY ABOUT SOME OF THE SOME OF
THE LANGUAGE I SEE ON HERE SOME
OF THE DISCUSSION HERE.
BECAUSE AGAIN IT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT IS BEING CREATED AS
A CEILING.
NOT A FLOOR --
WITH SOME OF THE DISCUSSION --
SOME THE WAY THIS IS WRITTEN
PROPOSITION NINETY A GUARANTEE A
SENSITIVE TO LOWER REVENUE
ESTIMATES WE CAN HAVE.
LOWER REVENUE WE GET STILL
COMMIT. TO YOUR FUNDING ARE
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM
ABOVE.
THE PROP NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE
IT'S REALLY WILL IS THERE THE
POLITICAL WILL WITHIN THIS BODY
TO DO THAT.
AND I'M NOT I DON'T NEED YOU TO
COMMENT ON THAT BUT AGAIN I JUST
WORK SOME OF SPEAKER BUYS INTO
THIS.
THIS THIS MANTRA THAT'S KIND OF
BEEN.
SATURATED IN INFUSED INTO THE
THING HERE I HAVE A JEEP
PROPOSITION ANYWHERE THEY GOT
MORE THAN NINETY EIGHT GUARANTEE
THAN THAN THAN THAN THAT.
IT'S ALMOST LIKE THAT'S A
PROBLEM NO THAT'S A GOOD THING --
BECAUSE IT'S TO SPEAK TO THE
INVESTMENT OUR CHILDREN IS THE
INVESTMENT A FUTURIST EIGHT I
THINK THIS THIS COMMITTEE REALLY
THIS YEAR AND IS IT NEEDS TO
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WE SHOULD NOT.
BE SET UP FOR THAT TYPE OF
THINKING WE SHOULD NOT JUST SIT
DOWN.
AND WE SHOULD NOT JUST KICKED
THE CAN DOWN THE ROAD WHAT WE
SHOULD --
AND THEN WHEN WE TALK ABOUT THE
FULL THEY CAN --
PROGRAM AND I'VE HAD.
YOU KNOW QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT
PROGRAM FOR A LONG TIME AND I
KNOW ON THE FACILITY SIDE A LOT
OF THAT MONEY IS NOT NINETY
EIGHT BUT IT'S STILL MONEY.
IN THAT COULD BE APPLIED TO
SOMETHING ELSE THE EDUCATION
SPHERE --
HOW MUCH EMPHASIS HAS THERE BEEN?
WE TALK ABOUT FULL THEY CAN --
FOR THOSE DISTRICTS THAT DON'T
HAVE HAVE FILLED AGAIN HOW MUCH
EMPHASIS HAS THERE BEEN WITHIN
THIS PROGRAM TO INCENTIVIZE.
PARTICULARLY TITLE ONE SCHOOLS
TO DEVELOP FULL THEY CAN --
BECAUSE I REALLY I THINK YOU
KNOW -- FOR
FOR FOR YOU KNOW MY OWN HOUSE I
WOULD SAY FULL THEY CAN THERE
WOULD BE A WANT.
BUT IN A TITLE ONE SCHOOL IT'S A
NEED.
I BECAUSE WE REALLY NEED TO
FOCUS ON THAT ACHIEVEMENT GAP.
SO HOW MUCH EMPHASIS HAS THE
PROGRAM PUT OR GOING FORWARD
WILL THERE BE.
AND REALLY INCENTIVIZING THOSE
THOSE THOSE TAIWAN.
OUR TITLE ONE SCHOOLS TO CREATE
FULL THEY CAN NEVER.
GARDEN PROGRAMS FASTER.
MORE EXPEDITIOUSLY YES YES THANK
YOU SOMETHING MEMBER O'DONNELL
THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION AFTER THE
CURRENT ROUND OF OF FUNDING THE
PROGRAM DOES PRIORITIZE --
DISTRICTS BASED THAT HAVE
RELATIVELY HIGH NUMBERS OF LOW
INCOME STUDENTS AND DISTRICT
THAT HAVE TROUBLE RAISING THEIR
LOCAL MATCH.
I ONE OF THAT SORT OF
INTERESTING THINGS IS THAT LOW
INCOME STUDENTS ARE LOW INCOME
DISTRICTS ALREADY A BIT.
MORE LIKELY TO OFFER FULL DAY
PROGRAMS THAT MORE AT THE MORE
AFFLUENT COUNTERPARTS.
AND SO IN PRIORITIZING THE WAY
THE PROGRAM IS STRUCTURED NOW
MORE FUNDING WILL PROBABLY GO TO
THOSE LOW INCOME DISTRICTS.
BUT IT WON'T GO FOR CONVERTING
PARKED AT A FULL DAY PROGRAMS
WILL GO FOR A SORT OF UPGRADES
AND RETROFITS WITHIN DISTRICT
THAT ARE ALREADY RUNNING THOSE
FULL DAY PROGRAMS.
SO THIS MONEY AS AN ONLY TO
INCENTIVIZE THE CREATION OF FULL
THEY CAN --
BUT TO ENHANCE THE FULL THEY CAN --
SPIRITS.
RIGHT DISTRICTS COULD USE THAT
IN EITHER WAY I THINK WHEN THE
PROGRAM WAS CREATED.
MANY MEMBERS WERE CONCERNED WERE
INTERESTED IN HAVING AN
INCENTIVE TO ENCOURAGE MORE --
FULL DAY PROGRAMS BUT ALSO ALLOW
UPGRADES POTENTIALLY --
BUT THE WAY THE PROGRAM HAS
UNFOLDED SO FAR IT'S KIND OF
BEEN THE REVERSE MOST OF THE
FUNDING IS GOING FOR UPGRADE
CERTAIN POLITICALLY SMALL CHAIR
SHARES GOING TO CONVERT PARKED
IN A FULL DAY.
WE SAY UPGRADE WHAT DOING BUYING
PURCHASING A TRAILER UP I MEAN
WHAT.
IN A CLASSROOM TO CLASSROOM WITH
A WHEN THEY HAVE TO MEET SOME
DIFFERENT STANDARD MAYBE.
YEAH THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
HAS KIND OF A LONG LIST OF
STANDARDS THAT KINDERGARTEN
CLASSROOMS ARE SUPPOSED TO MEET
EVERYTHING FROM KIND OF THE
HEIGHT OF THE FURNITURE IN THE
ROOM TO THE PLACEMENT OF THE
CLASSROOM RELATIVE TO THE PARENT
DROP OFF AREA.
AND SO DISTRICTS COULD APPLY FOR
FUNDING UNDER THIS GRANT TO MAKE
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES TO THAT
CLASSROOM OR EVEN CONSTRUCTING
NEW CLASSROOM IF THEY WANTED.
AND I WOULD JUST CAUTION WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT FULL THEY CAN --
RESEARCH BUT WHAT REALLY HAPPENS
BECAUSE NOW OFTENTIMES THEY'LL
BE HAPPY CAN --
AND THE TEACHER WILL SPEND THEY
WILL HAVE THEIR OWN CLASS HALF
THE DAY AND THEY WILL MOVE INTO
ANOTHER CLASSROOM GAVE THE
DISTRICTS DOING RIGHT.
THEY WILL MOVE INTO ANOTHER
CLASS FROM THE OTHER BASICALLY
MOST OF THE OTHER HALF OF THE
DAY SO YOU'LL ACTUALLY HAVE
DOUBLE COVERAGE IN THAT CLASS
AND YOU HAVE TO TEACHERS MOVING
AROUND THAT'S OFTEN HOW IT WORKS
I DON'T KNOW IF IT WORKS LIKE
THAT NEVER DISTRICT.
BUTWHAT THEN WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU GO TO FULL DAYS YOU HAVE ONE
TEACHER ALL DAY.
INSTEAD OF TWO TEACHERS PART OF
THE DAY SO YOU WON'T BE ABLE TO
DO THAT PULL OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE STUDENT CENTER
MAYBE NEED A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUPPORT SO I I JUST HOPE THAT
PEOPLE.
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
THE CLASSROOM TO NOT JUST WILL
THEY CAN --
GREAT THERE WE GO.
RIGHT AND I THINK THE WAY YOU
ARTICULATED IS EXACTLY HOW IT
TENDS TO PLAY OUT IN IN PRACTICE
IT TENDS TO BE PARKED A PROGRAMS
ARE TO TEACHERS SWITCHING OFF.
AND WHEN WE TALK TO DISTRICTS
MANY OF THEM SAID THEIR TEACHERS
DID PREFER AT BECAUSE THEY HAD
THAT ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO NAY
COULD DO THOSE KINDS OF
PULLOUT'S YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT --
WITH MORE OF A FULL DAY MODEL
IT'S TYPICALLY JUST ONE TEACHER
THROUGHOUT THE DAY.
IN SOME CASES THEY MAY HAVE AN
INSTRUCTIONAL AIDE ALTHOUGH A
LOT OF DISTRICTS DON'T PROVIDE
THAT.
AND SO IT SOME GIVEN THE CHOICE
BETWEEN THE TWO MODELS SOME
TEACHERS AND AND SOME PARENTS DO
PREFER THE PART DAY APPROACH.
RATE IN AND AGAIN PLANNING FOR A
KINDERGARTEN CLASSROOM --
THERE'S A LOT OF PLANNING
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF HANDS
ON OUT OF STUFF.
PRIOR TO THE START OF THE DAY
AND THEY NEED MORE TIME OFF OF
PLANNING AND AND AND AND TO
CREATE THOSE THOSE DIFFERENT
ACTIVITIES.
AND THE MANIPULATIVESIX CETERA
THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH THOSE
ACTIVITIES AND CLASSROOM
TYPICALLY GONNA TAKE MORE TIME
AND YOU KNOW I IS A MIDDLE SKATE
MIDDLE SCHOOL TEACHER FOR A LONG
TIME.
TO SO THANK YOU AND I DON'T KNOW
OF ANY OTHERS WISH TO COMMENT ON
ANY OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
QUITE OFTEN HEARING IT TEARS
OKAY WITH THAT.
I SHOULDN'T WHERE THIRTY SO WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MONITOR AT THE FIRST
ROUND OF THE HUNDRED MILLION --
THE OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION JUST CLOSE --
THE FIRST ROUND OF APPLICATIONS --
TO THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE
MILLION --
AROUND IN THE RECEIVED
APPLICATIONS TOTALING TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY TWO MILLION AND
IT'S BOTH THE GIVING --
SCHOOLS OPPORTUNITY TO UPGRADE
THEIR FACILITIES TO ME A CD
STANDARDS AS WELL AS REMOVE
BARRIERS --
TO PROVIDE FULL DAY KINDERGARTEN
SO WE CONTINUE TO THINK THROUGH --
THE INCENTIVES --
THROUGH THE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION.
I'M NOT SURE WHO SPOKE TO
PROTECT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
THIS YEAR'S BUDGET FOR FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX MILLION FOR
SPECIAL AT FOUR HUNDRED OF ITS
ONGOING IF I'M CORRECT --
AND I I BELIEVE THAT THERE'S A
THRESHOLD FOR A DISTRICT IS IN
THERE WITH REGARD TO SPECIAL ED
POPULATION.
YES THERE IS A THRESHOLD --
IT'S IT TAKES INTO ACCOUNT THE
PERCENTAGE OF A DVD PEOPLE'S AND
ALSO THE PERCENTAGE OF STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES IN THEIR
DISTRICT COMPARED TO THE
STATEWIDE AVERAGE --
AND TO SPEAK IN MORE SPECIFICS I
WOULD HAVE TO CALL A ONCE I
COLLEAGUES BUT IT'S A GOOD BUT
AGAIN THE THE THE INTENT OF THIS
MONEY IS THAT NOT THAT IT NOT
ONLY GO. TO AYE AP DRIVEN
SERVICES IS THAT CORRECT --
I BELIEVE THAT'S CORRECT BUT
DESPITE I WOULD HAVE TO HAVE MY
COLLEAGUES TO GIVE SOME MORE
SPECIFICS.
GOOD MORNING LISA RESIDENTS HE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YES THAT'S CORRECT IT IS TO GO --
TO IT IT'S INTENDED TO GO TO NON
AP RELATED SERVICES IN ORDER TO
IMPROVE THE OUTCOMES OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS TECHNICALLY
NOT EVEN TECHNICALLY UNDER
FEDERAL AND STATE LAW ALL
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS
SHOULD BE.
RECEIVING ALL THAT SERVICES.
REQUIRED IN THERE I A PIECE OF
THIS IS KIND OF A TARGETED
INVESTMENT. TO IMPROVE THE
OUTCOMES AND SPECIAL JUST CATION
STUDENTS AND ALSO TO PREVENT
STUDENTS WHO MIGHT BE AT RISK OF
BEING IDENTIFIED AS SPECIAL
EDUCATION TO RECEIVE ADDITIONAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT.
PRIOR TO AN AP [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND I THIS IS ANOTHER QUESTION I
DON'T EXPECT YOU TO HAVE THIS
DATA NOW BUT I I ASSUME THERE'S
YOUR SOME SCHEDULE OR AND STORE
SOME DATA RELATIVE.
TO HOW MANY SPECIAL ED STUDENTS
HE DISTRICT.
EACH OF THE THOUSAND DISTRICTS
AND STATE CALIFORNIA HAS.
CORRECT YEAH THANK YOU
[inaudible]
MR MEDINA.
THANK YOU --
KIND OF FOLLOWING UP WITH MISTER
O'DONNELL AND AND HOW WE FIND --
K. TWELVE EDUCATION.
I HAVEN'T BEEN A CLASSROOM
TEACHER KINDERGARTEN TEACHER I
UNDERSTAND THE PREPARATION
THAT'S NEEDED --
TO TO BE EFFECTIVE AT THAT GRADE
LEVEL.
BUT I I WANNA DRAW THE ATTENTION
TO LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
TO PAGE. FIVE TO THE CENSUS
BUREAU DATA [inaudible]
ANNA AND AS I SAID AT THE
BEGINNING I WAS A TEACHER FOR
THIRTY FOUR YEARS SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER --
AND AS I SIT HERE --
IT SEEMS LIKE ALL OF A SUDDEN.
THE THE POSITION RELATIVE
POSITION A PER STUDENT --
FUNDING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MOVED UP TWENTY
NOTCHES.
WITHOUT ANY ADDITIONAL FUNDING --
WITH WITH WHAT YOU'RE PRESENTING
HERE --
BECAUSE AS YOU PROBABLY --
WERE ALLUDING TO THE FIGURE THAT
I'VE SEEN.
THROUGHOUT THE YEARS IS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS IT SOMEWHERE IN
THE LOWER FORTIES.
IN PER PUPIL SPENDING --
AND YOU.
THIS THE FIRST TIME I EVER SEE
[inaudible]
ANYWHERE.
CLOSE TO THE TWENTY SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE.
ELABORATE THAT BECAUSE I'M VERY
SURPRISED BY THIS.
SURE SO I THINK THIS GOES BACK
TO A LITTLE BIT OF THE LEG IN
THE CENSUS BUREAU DATA HAD A LOT
OF THOSE NUMBERS ARE MORE
EFFECTIVE OF WHERE THE STATE
STOOD KIND OF IN THE RECESSION
YEARS.
A TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
OR TWO OF THE BEST YEARS THAT IN
SCHOOL FUNDING THAT THE STATE
HAS HAD IN A VERY LONG TIME AND
BOTH OF THOSE YEARS FUNDING WAS
GOING NEARLY 10% YEAR OVER YEAR.
AND SO AS THE CENSUS BUREAU HAS
KIND OF UPDATED ITS DATA AND
INCORPORATED THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
CALIFORNIA HAS MOVED UP PRETTY
SIGNIFICANTLY.
A WE WERE RANKED --
FAIRLY IN THE LOW FORTIES DURING
THE RECESSION YEARS BUT I WITH
THE MOVING UP WITH SOME OF THOSE
INCREASES AND PROBABLY WILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE UP A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE THE PAST FEW YEARS WE'VE
ALSO HAD.
SOME FAIRLY STEADY INCREASES IN
SCHOOL FUNDING BEYOND THAT.
I I YOU KNOW I'M GONNA GO OUT
AND AND AND AND CHECK BUT I
DON'T SEE ANYONE AGREED WITH THE
WITH THE THOSE NUMBERS SO IF I
COULD JUST ADD THE THE OTHER --
FACTOR THAT YOU YOU CAN NEED TO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION IS THE
COST OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A LOT
OF DIFFERENT.
NUMBERS FLOATING AROUND AS TO
WHERE WE RANK --
WHEN YOU DO TAKE INTO THE COST
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA THE COST
OF DOING BUSINESS THE?
HOW FAR THAT THE DOLLARS THAT
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICT RECEIVED
HOW FOR THE CONSTRUCTION HOW
MUCH THEY CAN SPEND TO IN THE ON
THE ON THE EDUCATIONAL SERVICES?
VERSES THE THE OTHER OTHER COSTS --
THE OTHER IT COSTS A LOT MORE TO
DO BUSINESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO TO TO DO --
ALL YOUR UTILITY COSTS --
AO.
LAND BECAUSE BUILDING COSTS
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE ALL THESE
COSTS ARE HIGHER IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO WHEN YOU WHEN YOU FACTOR
THAT IN.
AT NEO CALIFORNIA DROPS
PRECIPITOUSLY RELATIVE TO OTHER
STATES IN TERMS OF RANKINGS.
WHEN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THINGS
LIKE CLASS SIZE --
IN CALIFORNIA IT COMPARED TO
OTHER STATES ARE COMPARED TO
STATES THAT SPEND MORE OF PER
PUPIL AS YOU COMPARE
CALIFORNIA'S CLASS SIZE TO WHAT
I UNDERSTAND.
CLASS SIZES IN PLACES LIKE
CONNECTICUT --
IT IT'S DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT --
AND DRAMATICALLY DIFFERENT OF
WHAT WE ASK OUR TEACHERS IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO --
WITH A CLASS OF THIRTY SIX
STUDENTS OR THAT YOU WOULD ASK A
TEACHER AND I'M JUST USING
CONNECTICUT BECAUSE I THINK THAT
MIGHT BE ONE OF THEM.
UP WITH THE CLASS SIZE OF TWENTY
AND AND I THINK THE RESULTS
MIGHT MAYOR --
BEAR THAT OUT THAT'S TRUE WE DO
WE DO HAVE LARGER CLASS SIZES
THAN MOST OTHER STATES
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER MURATSUCHI VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN.
I HAVE A QUESTION FOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
YOU KNOW AS THE BUDGET
REPRESENTATIVES FOR THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WHAT IS THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IS.
TO MESSAGE TO DISTRICTS LIKE LOS
ANGELES UNIFIED LIKE OAKLAND
UNIFIED THAT INCIDENT JUST BEEN
COMING OUT OF THESE TEACHER
STRIKES THAT HAVE BEEN
HIGHLIGHTING --
IN THEIR EYES A CRISIS
[inaudible]
OF THE LACK OF THE INADEQUATE
STATE FUNDING --
FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION.
THE THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD
WOULD NOTE THAT --
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO
DIMINISH THE EXPERIENCES OF
DISTRICTS LIKE THAT BUT I THINK
WE WOULD ALSO POINT --
TO THE FLEXIBILITY CERTAINLY
THAT HAS BEEN PROVIDED --
WITHIN THE LOWER CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA OVER THE LAST HANDFUL OF
YEARS SINCE ITS ENACTMENT --
AND I THINK THE PROPOSAL --
WITH THE COASTERS --
PAY DOWN PARTICULARLY ON BEHALF
OF EMPLOYERS THIS YEAR --
IS INTENDED SORT OF RECOGNIZE
THAT YES WE WE SEE THESE
PRESSURES OF GROWING COST WITHIN
DISTRICTS THAT I'M OFTEN YOU
KNOW THEY FEEL --
THERE REALLY CAUGHT BETWEEN A
ROCK AND A HARD PLACE AND WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO TRY TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT WITH SOME OF THAT
FUNDING --
ALSO I KNOW AT A LATER HEARING
IN THIS COMMITTEE I BELIEVE
YOU'LL BE HEARING FROM --
MIGHT FIND WITH THICK MATT AND I
I THINK HE COULD ALSO SHED SOME
LIGHT AS WELL AND INTO THE WORK
THAT.
A FIGMENT IS DOING IN WAYS THAT
WE'VE --
INCREASE THEIR BUDGET --
IN RECENT YEARS SO THAT HE CAN
BE BETTER RESOURCE TO BE ABLE --
TO HELP DISTRICTS BEFORE THINGS --
MAYBE GET TO TO A A WORST POINT --
THEN I WOULD ALSO POINT TO THE A
STATEWIDE SYSTEM SUPPORT THAT
WE'VE BEEN BUILDING UP OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS --
MEET WITH THE INTENT OF
PROVIDING --
DISTRICTS IN AND COUNTY OFFICES
WITH THE SUPPORTS --
TO REALLY BE ABLE --
TO IMPROVE OUTCOMES FOR STUDENTS
HOW IT THERE TING TEACHERS ARE
HAVE YOU.
THAT THE STATE IN THIS
ADMINISTRATION CONTINUES --
TO PUT A LOT OF FOCUS IN TO BE
ABLE TO IMPROVE THAT.
I THANK GOD CERTAINLY --
YOU KNOW APPRECIATE.
TO IN A SOME OF THE THE THE
GOVERNOR'S --
A PROPOSALS AS TOO QUICK K<c.cyan></c>
THROUGH TWELVE EDUCATION AND AND
CLEARLY --
INCREASES BETTER THAN A DECREASE --
BUT I I KNOW THAT THE LAST TIME
THE FOLLOWING UP ON THEM THIS
MEDINA IS COMMENT ABOUT THE
PEOPLE SPENDING.
I KNOW THAT THE THE LAST
EDUCATION WEEKLY --
A RANKING OF CALIFORNIA --
IN TERMS OF PER PUPIL SPENDING --
TAKING INTO ACCOUNT THE COST OF
LIVING I BELIEVE WAS FORTY FIRST
IN THE NATION I I BELIEVE THAT'S
BEEN THE NUMBER THAT'S BEEN --
CITED TO STATE --
SO I ASK.
TO THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE YOU
KNOW WHY IS THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE FORTY
FIRST IN THE NATION IN PER
PEOPLE SPENDING.
SO I WOULD --
ECHO THE LA OATH COMMENTS AND
ALSO --
MISTRESS WAITRESS COMMENTS AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION --
IN JUST POINTING OUT THAT THAT
DATA --
UNFORTUNATELY IS LAGGED SELECT
DELI --
POINTEDOUT THAT RIGHT THE
RANKING THAT YOU'VE DONE YOUR
CITING WITH ED WEEK --
IS BASED ON FIFTEEN SIXTEEN DATA
BUT ALSO AS A PART OF EDUCATION
NOTED --
TAKES INTO ACCOUNT A COST OF
LIVING ADJUSTMENT USING WHAT'S
CALLED A COMPARABLE WAGE INDEX
WHICH BASICALLY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT --
SALARIES FOR NON EDUCATIONAL --
EMPLOYEES.
IN IN WHATEVER REGION THEY'RE
THEY'RE LOOKING DATA WERE IN THE
LOW TWENTIES WITH THAT
ADJUSTMENT FOR COST OF LIVING
THAT TAKES US UP TO FORTY FIRST
BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT --
THAT NOT WITHSTANDING THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT ONE WAY OR
THE OTHER --
SENSE.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THE LC A FAST
HAS RECEIVED JUST OVER TEN
BILLION DOLLARS --
UP THROUGH THE CURRENT BUDGET
THAT'S PROPOSED NOW AND
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT ON THE
K. TWELVE SITE HAS ALSO RECEIVED
THIRTEEN POINT SIX BILLION
DOLLARS AN INCREASE FUNDING.
SENSE THOSE FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
LEVEL SO WE WOULD ASSUME LIKE
THE LA --
POINTED OUT THAT --
WE WOULD START SEEING A RANKING
NOW IS AS THE THE GEAR START TO
SORT OF CATCH UP --
THAT THESE RANKINGS ARE DONE FOR
RESEARCH HERE BREAKING THAT'S A
LITTLE BIT MORE INDICATIVE OF
YOU SUGGESTED AS A A MORE
BURGEONING ECONOMY.
AND IF I CAN JUST GATHER SO THE
LATEST DATA FROM AND WE COULD
ACTUALLY FROM TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN SO.
FOR AT LEASTFOUR YEARS OLD --
I THINK THE STATE PUBLIC DID
STAND IN THE FORTIES AT THAT
POINT -- BUT
GIVEN THE NEW SORT OF THAT
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES THE STATE
PROVIDED IN SOME SUBSEQUENT
YEARS ARE PROBABLY NO MORE IN
THE MID HIRTIES.
NOW YOU MAY NOT STILL BE
SATISFIED WITH THAT RANKING
COMPARED WITH OTHER STATES AND
YOU MIGHT WANT TO IMPROVE UPON
IT MORE.
AND WE CAN HELP YOU THINK ABOUT
WAYS TO DO THAT.
THE HOW WELL THE ECONOMY IS DONE
THE PAST FEW YEARS OUR RANKING
HAS BEEN MOVING UP RELATIVE TO
OTHER STATES.
HI I I APPRECIATE THAT --
YOU KNOW STATISTICS --
AND AND AND NUMBERS CAN BE
DIFFERENT --
DEPENDING ON WHO YOU'RE.
TALKING TO AND WHAT THEIR AGENDA
IS -- BUT I
I THINK YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS
AT THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT --
YOU KNOW OAKLEY UNIFIED A I
BELIEVE THEY JUST --
TO THE OAKLAND SCHOOL BOARD JUST
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY'RE GONNA
HAVE TO LAY OFF --
OF OVER A HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
CLOSE DOWN PROGRAMS --
IN ORDER TO AFFORD AT THIS 11% --
TEACHER PAY INCREASE THAT --
THAT THE THAT THEY NEGOTIATED TO
SETTLE THE OAKLAND STRIKE AND
AND AND SO THE REALITY IS THAT
YOU KNOW WHILE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW HOW HOW HOW GOOD WE ARE
DOING IN TERMS OF INCREASING
STATE FUNDING THE THE REALITY
THAT THAT THE THAT THAT ARE THAT
ARE THE SCHOOL CHILDREN AND OUR
TEACHERS IN OUR AND OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE FACING --
ARE -- OUR
OUR OUR OUR CUTS AND AND AND JOB
LOSSES AND AND PROGRAM.
A PROGRAM LOSSES AND SO.
YOU KNOW I I YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD
OF THE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW
THIS IS BEING DRIVEN BY.
INCREASING FIXED COSTS --
AND I KNOW THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS ONE OF THOSE BIG --
ACOSTA BUT I I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT WE DON'T LOSE SIDE IN
A WAY WE WE DON'T --
IN A WHILE WE'RE AT PATTING
OURSELVES ON THE BACK IN IN
TERMS OF YOU KNOW HOW WE'RE
DOING ON ON K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION FUNDING THE REALITY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES --
ARE JOB LOSSES IN PROGRAM CUTS --
AND AND I I THINK THIS GOES TO
MR DOLLARS POINT ABOUT HOW WE
NEED -- TO
MAKE THE POLITICAL COMMITMENT
HAVE THE POLITICAL WILL IN ORDER.
TO TO PROVIDE ADEQUATE FUNDING --
IF I MAY A MINIATURE --
I WOULD LIKE --
TO SEGUE --
TO THE LA ALL PRESENTATION AND
ESPECIALLY THE ALLY --
YOUR YOUR REPORT WHICH I YOU
HAVE IN AND AND PAGE --
FIFTEEN OF YOUR REPORT --
THE L. C. F. F. FUNDING TARGETS
AND HOW THE STATE.
HAS BEEN --
A PROGRESSING BASED ON THE
FUNDING TARGETS THAT WERE
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED IN --
TWENTY THIRTEEN YOU RECOGNIZE
THIS GRASS YES AND SO WHAT WOULD
YOU SAY THAT THIS GRAPH AND OR
OR THE THE LCF FUNDING TARGETS.
THAT WE ESTABLISH IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN YOU KNOW WAS THE THEY
THEY WERE THEY THEY THE GUIDING
BENCHMARKS AGAINST WHICH WE
MEASURE OUR PROGRESS TOWARD --
THE THE THE GOAL THAT WE SET IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN IN TERMS OF
GETTING BACK TO THE PRE
RECESSION --
FUNDING LEVELS FOR THE STATE.
WHEN WE CREATED THAT WHEN THE
STATE CREATED THOSE TARGETS BACK
IN? TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN I I THINK ORIGINALLY IN
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL THAT WAS
TO GET BACK TO THE SEVEN EIGHT
LEVELS SOME MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THOUGHT THAT WASN'T
AMBITIOUS ENOUGH AND SO WE SET
TARGET THERE A LITTLE BIT.
ACTUALLY ABOVE WHERE WE WERE
BACK IN --
TWO THOUSAND AND I THINK THE WAY
WE HAVE COME UP WITH THOSE
TARGETS AS WE TRY TO THINK ABOUT
WELL HOW MUCH MIGHT THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE GROW OVER THE NEXT
SEVEN EIGHT YEARS.
AND WHAT BY THE STATE
REALISTICALLY BE ABLE TO ACHIEVE
WITH THAT GROWTH.
SO THAT'S WHERE WE CAME UP WITH
THAT KIND OF THESE TARGETS I
THINK THE REASON WE REACH THEM
AHEAD OF SCHEDULE IS BECAUSE THE
ECONOMY JUST ENDED UP BEING A
LOT BETTER THAN WE THOUGHT IT
WAS -- THE
MINIMUM GUARANTEED GREW QUITE A
BIT PARTICULARLY IN FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN AND FOURTEEN FIFTEEN AS
YOU SEE ON THIS CHART.
AND SO THAT'S KIND OF BROUGHT US
TO WHERE WE ARE TODAY --
SO.
WERE FINALLY WE'RE BACK TO WE'RE
ACTUALLY --
WE GOT BACK TO SEVEN EIGHT
LEVELS A FEW YEARS AGO AND NOW
WE STARTED TO PASSING THEM
BECAUSE THE ECONOMY HAS
CONTINUED TO GROW --
BUT NOW I THINK JUST FOUR MONTHS
SHORT ABOUT LONGEST ECONOMIC
EXPANSION EVER AND SO THAT'S A
GIVEN US MORE ROOM TO INCREASE
FUNDING BEYOND JUST GETTING BACK
THIS OKAY.
BUT MY QUESTION WAS THESE
FUNDING TARGETS WORTHY GUIDING
BENCHMARKS --
BY WHICH WE MEASURE OUR PROGRESS
TOWARD THE GOAL THAT WE STATUS
IN.
THAT THESE TARGETS OF KIND OF
BEEN THE FOCUS OF OUR BUDGET
DELIBERATIONS THE GEFFEN LOCUSTS
AND AND AND THE PLANNING TOOL.
TO REACH THE GOAL THAT WE SET IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND IT'S THE WAY
THAT DISTRICTS HAVE BEEN
THINKING ABOUT THEIR BUDGETS
THEY BEEN THINKING ABOUT HOW
MUCH OF THIS SORT OF GAP IS
GOING TO BE CLOSED EACH YEAR
WHAT'S THE COST OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENT GOING TO BE.
THAT'S KIND OF BEEN.
HOW HOW DISTRICTS THINK ABOUT
THEIR?
IN IN FACT IN YOUR REPORT YOU
YOU TALK ABOUT HOW THE STATE
REACHED THE LCF A FUNNY TARGET --
TWO YEARS AHEAD OF SCHEDULE AND
SO CLEARLY WE'RE MEASURING OUR
PROGRESS BASED ON THE FUNDING
TARGETS THAT WE STAFF IS CORRECT
YEAH I THINK OF TRADE --
BUT NOW WE DO NOT HAVE FUNDING
TARGETS IS THAT CORRECT.
THAT'S CORRECT SO NOW WE'RE
WE'VE CREATED A STATE POLICY
THAT WILL AUTOMATICALLY PROVIDE
A COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT FOR
THOSE TARGETS.
AND THAT'S KIND OF A LITTLE BIT
OF RETURN TO HOW THINGS WORKED
SAY TEN OR FIFTEEN YEARS AGO
WHERE IT WAS JUST THE CURRENT
LEVEL ADJUSTED EACH YEAR.
SORRY YET BUT IT BUT THE THAT
THE JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
THE FUNDING TARGETS ONLY GOT US
BACK TO WHERE WE WERE --
IT IN --
SEVEN OH EIGHT WITH.
THE SOME COST OF OF OF LIVING
ADJUSTMENTS THEY GOT US BACK TO
ABOVE THAT LEVEL --
PARTLY BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY WANTED WE
WANTED TARGETS THAT WERE
SOMEWHAT AMBITIOUS AND WE TRY TO
STRIKE A BALANCE BETWEEN WHAT
WAS.
PART OF WHAT WE WERE IT WHAT WE
COULD FIND WITHIN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS AND KIND OF WHERE
WE WANTED TO BE.
AND THE TARGETS KIND OF
REFLECTED THAT KIND OF BALANCE
BETWEEN THOSE TWO OBJECTIVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MR O'DONNELL.
YEAH I I I THINK I I MAY WANT TO
DEFEND THE GOVERNOR HERE FOR A
SECOND --
BECAUSE I THINK WHAT THIS BODY
KEEPS DOING IT KEEPS DEFINING
THE PROBLEM BUT NOT SOLVING THE
PROBLEM WHEN IT COMES TO
EDUCATION FUNDING --
WHEN THE BUDGET IS IS IS?
IT'S A TEAM EFFORT IT'S NOT JUST
ABOUT THE GOVERNOR IT'S ALSO
ABOUT THIS BODY.
AND WE CAN FAULT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET BUT IN THE END.
WE OWN THE APPROVED BUDGET.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHERE WE COME
IN MISTER MERCY JEFF TO GET
AGREE WITH AND I AND I
APPRECIATE YOU ADVOCATING I
THINK.
IT TAKES MORE WILL FROM THIS
BODY. TO PUSH FOR MORE THAN.
NINETY EIGHT AND I THINK WE YOU
KNOW IT'S IT'S BEEN A MUTUAL FOR
EXERCISE WE'VE BEEN AWARE AND WE
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE ALL SETTLE FOR
THIS THIS NINETY EIGHT BEING THE
CEILING.
AS OPPOSED TO THE FLOOR.
AND I THINK THIS YEAR I
HOPEFULLY THE POLITICAL WILL.
ANNA POLICY DESIRE WILL BE THERE
TO GO WELL ABOVE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT WE NEED A STRONGER
COMMITMENT FROM THIS LEGISLATURE
SHIRT AND CERTAINLY THE GOVERNOR
AS WELL.
BUT AGAIN I THINK SOME OF THAT'S
US WE NEED TO LOOK IN THE MIRROR
TO AND SEE WHAT OUR ROLE.
IN THIS EXERCISE IS AS WELL.
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU I'LL
TRY TO WRAP THIS UP HERE IN AS
ALWAYS I WHAT MY COLLEAGUES.
TO SPEAK UP FIRST --
WITH THAT MISTER GALLAGHER
WELCOME TO SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER
TWO BY THE WAY.
GLAD TO BE HERE --
I I DIDN'T HAVE. TOO MUCH MORE
TO ADD IN THERE I JUST --
NO ONE IS.
I NOTICED THAT THERE WAS THE
DECLINE IN.
THE CLIENT ENROLLMENT DO WE HAVE
LIKE A REASONING FOR THAT WHILE
WE'RE SEEN AS THE CLIENTS IN A
ROMAN RIGHT NOW.
SURE I CAN SPEAK TO THAT THE
BIGGEST FACTOR HAS BEEN AND A
DROP IN THE NUMBER OF BIRTHS IN
THE STATE A STARTING AROUND THE
TIME THE GREAT RECESSION BEGAN
THE NUMBER OF BIRTHS DROPPED
THAT MAY NOT BE A BIG SURPRISE.
ABOUT WHAT WAS SURPRISING TO
SOME DEMOGRAPHERS IS THAT BIRTH
NEVER PICKED UP IN THE RECOVERY
STARTED AND SO EVERY YEAR THAT
GOES BY EACH COHORT OF INCOMING
STUDENTS A LITTLE BIT SMALLER
THAN THE ONE AT YOUR PLACE AND
AND SO WITH THAT.
DECLINE WE THINK THAT NOT JUST
FOR THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS BUT
REALLY FOR THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE.
REST ASSURED THE GALLAGHER
FAMILY YOU'RE DOING YOUR PART BY
AND WE HAVE DONE OUR PART OF THE
SIX KIDS RIGHT. FIVE FIVE AND
THEN THE OBVIOUS I THINK IT WAS
ALREADY KIND OF TALKED ABOUT BUT
A LITTLE BIT OF A CONCERN I I
THINK I UNDERSTAND.
WHAT THE GOVERNOR IS TRYING TO
DO HOWEVER?
WE KNOW THAT LIKE IF WE GET HIT
WITH A MILD RECESSION.
WE COULD HAVE A REAL BIG BUDGET
PROBLEM ON OUR HANDS AND I THINK
IF WE CUT A TIRE HANDS WITH BY
ELIMINATING THE TRUE UP.
YOU KNOW HAVING SOME OF THAT
FLEXIBILITY CERTAINLY WANT TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP
EDUCATION HOLE EVEN WHEN WE GO
INTO --
TOUGHER TIMES BUT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
WE HAVE SOME FLEXIBILITY THERE
SO I MEAN I THINK WE SHOULD KIND
OF THINK THROUGH THAT.
MAYBE A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE EVEN
THE L. L. AS WARNED HEY.
A MILD RECESSION WE COULD HAVE
FORTY YOU KNOW WAS A FORTY
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT --
ON OUR HANDS SO.
I JUST THINK THAT SOMETHING TO
BE THINKING ABOUT AS WE AS WE
MOVE FORWARD AND IF WE MAKE ANY
CHANGES --
TO THE PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR ME
I THINK WE HAVE TO KIND OF KEEP
THAT IN MIND --
AND THEN LAW AND THEN I JUST
WANT.
TO AND A BECAUSE I KNOW --
SIMON O'DONNELL IS REALLY WORKED
ON THIS A LOT TOO IS I THINK
TRYING TO MAKE THAT
PRIORITIZATION AND AND SOME
WOMEN MARRIED TO DELUDED TO IT.
EQUALIZATION FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION FUNDING I THINK IT'S
GONNA BE A BIG ISSUE.
THAT WE NEED TO ADDRESS AS WELL --
AND TRYING TO MAKE THAT A
PRIORITY.
AT SOME POINT TO OUR TO OUR
EDUCATION BUDGET AS WELL SO.
BUT THAT ALL.
TURN IT BACK OVER TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU --
IS JUST A FEW THINGS I TRY TO
WRAP THIS UP SO I I APPRECIATE
THE CONVERSATION ABOUT --
PER PEOPLE FUNDING IS MISTER
MEDINA SAID OUR CLASS SIZES I
THINK IT'S IT'S HARD IT'S APPLES
AND ORANGES NOT ALWAYS APPLES TO
APPLES ORANGES TO ORANGES BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS CALIFORNIA.
IS IN THE BOTTOM HALF.
IN PER PUPIL FUNDING AND CLASS
SIZES AND SO REGARDLESS WHETHER
YOU LOOK AT OUR COST OF LIVING.
WE'RE STILL NOWHERE NEAR --
THE THE MIDPOINT NOWHERE NEAR
THOSE EAST COAST --
STATES THAT HAVE HIGHER OUTCOMES
FOR THEIR STUDENTS WITH SIMILAR
DEMOGRAPHICS AND SO I THINK YOU
KNOW IT IS WHAT IT IS SO WE
CAN'T -- RUN
FROM THAT --
AND SO WE DO NEED --
TO TO THINK ABOUT AS HE SAID --
EDUCATION CHAIR O'DONNELL YOU
KNOW TRULY FUNDING OUR SCHOOLS
ARE WHAT WE VALUE BUT I ALSO
NOTE THAT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
THERE ARE TRADE OFFS TOMORROW
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE TALKING
ABOUT HIGHER AT WHO ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT HOW WE SHOULD
FULLY FUND THE UC.
AND CSU WELL THOSE ARE THE SAME.
POTS OF MONEY THAT WE'RE BE AT
WOULD BE --
VYING FOR IF WE TALK ABOUT GOING
ABOVE --
NINETY EIGHT MAY WE CAN LOOK AT
OTHER SUBCOMMITTEES AND MAYBE
SHUT DOWN THREE PRESENTS SET
DOWN THREE PRESENT THIS TO IT --
SO YOU KNOW THAT'S JUST A LARGER
BUDGET CONTEXT BUT WE HAVE
CERTAINLY OUR JOBS ADVOCATE FOR
FOR AT FOR EDUCATION HERE TODAY.
I I DO WANT TO TALK ABOUT THESE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE THAT ARE.
HAVING STRIKES IN TROUBLE IN THE
CONTRACTS THAT THEIR RIGHTFULLY --
TRYING TO DO RIGHT BY THEIR
TEACHERS WHO HAD ARE ENACT
INADEQUATELY PAID FOR THE TOP
JOBS WE HAVE HUGE CLASS SIZES
AND COST OF LIVING IS OUTRAGEOUS
A YOU KNOW TO ME TEACHERS.
CAN EVEN IF YOU'RE COME CLOSE TO
BUY A HOME IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT THEY THAT THEY THEY TEACH
AND THAT BEING SAID.
SOME OF THAT INFORMATION WORK
WORK FOR GETTING A SHOWING THAT.
EVEN IF WE HAVE MILD INCREASES
IN OUR BUDGET LIKE WE HAVE THIS
YEAR FOR THE NEXT COUPLE YEARS
THESE DISTRICTS CAN'T AFFORD.
THEIR CONTRACTS AND IF WE HAVE
ANY.
POSITIVE ECONOMY OR A DEATH.
THESE DISTRICTS ARE GOING TO GO
UNDER.
SO WHAT WHAT DO YOU ALL SAY
ABOUT THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
TRYING TO KEEP PEACE AND KEEP
THE KIDS.
A IN A SCHOOL WITH THAT YOU KNOW
ADEQUATELY TRAINED TEACHER WHO'S
ADEQUATELY COMPENSATED.
AND JUST THE MATHEMATICS DON'T
ADD UP.
SO YOU KNOW.
IT EVENTUALLY IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'LL COME BACK TO US TO DEAL
WITH THE MASS SO.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THAT YEAH
SO SO WE'RE WE'RE CERTAINLY
SEEING THAT AS WELL AND AND YOU
KNOW?
SO THEY YOU KNOW THE THE THE IN
IN OAKLAND THAT WHAT MAY BE
HAPPENING HERE IN TOWN --
THAT SYNDICATE OF OF THAT BUT
IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IT'S
HAPPENING IN DISTRICTS IS --
WITH THAT DON'T AT THE MOMENT
HAVE LABOR ISSUES AS WELL IF
IT'S HAPPENING I MEAN.
THE OTHER PART PART OF IT IS
DECLINING ENROLLMENT WHICH WE WE
DISCUSSED EARLIER --
THE STATE YOU KNOW MOST
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE ARE ARE
IN DECLINING ENROLLMENT AS WELL
BUT A BIG PART OF IT IS ALSO YO.
YO WE DISCUSS THE THE INCREASED
IN THAT THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
IDENTIFIED FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
SERVICES AND AND THE COST OF
THOSE SERVICES.
AS WELL AS JUST JUST IS JOE THE
THE COST INCREASES THAT YO THE
INCREASE IN THE COST OF LIVING
THE INCREASING IN IN IN PENSION
COSTS AND AND THINGS LIKE THAT
THOSE ARE ALL.
ALL CONTRIBUTING FROM FROM
DIFFERENT ANGLES AND EURO --
IN MY HEAD.
PRESENTATION EARLIER AYE AYE A
YOU KNOW EMPHASIZE THE THE NEED
TO BE.
YOUR FORCES DATEABLE INVESTMENTS
I THINK THAT'S THAT'S VERY
CRITICAL FOR FOR DISTRICTS GOING
FOR THAT I HOPE IN IN LOOKING AT
SO THE STRUCTURE OF NINETY EIGHT
AND THE THE STRUCTURE OF OF YOU
KNOW THE STATE'S BUDGET GOING
FORWARD THAT YOU CONSIDER --
NOT JUST SORT OF THE STATE'S
FLEXIBILITY IN HOW THE STATE
YOUR WILL REACT OR NEED TO
REACTIVE REDUCTIONS IN REVENUES
BUT ALSO WHAT WHAT.
WHAT THAT DOES TO LOCAL AGENCIES
AND SCHOOL DISTRICT TEMPERATURE
WHERE IN THEIR THEIR ABILITY? TO
TO TO REACTIVATE TO CHANGING
ECONOMIC AND FISCAL
CIRCUMSTANCES.
EVER ALEXANDER WITH DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I'M JUST TO ADD TO
THAT ON THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH --
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION PARTNERS
AS WELL AS FISCAL MANAGEMENT --
ASSISTANCE TEAM AND THAT THE
COUNTY OFFICES AND THEN THE
DISTRICTS THAT ARE AFFECTED AND
GOING THROUGH --
SOME OF THESE FISCAL --
FISCAL DIFFICULTIES AT THIS TIME
AND MONITORING THE SITUATION
VERY CLOSELY.
SO I NEED IS PUSHED BACK A
LITTLE BIT YEAH WHAT'SYOUR
ADVICE TO US IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THAT ARE.
THAT ARE --
ADOPTING THESE THESE --
CONTRACTS IN MAKING DECISIONS
THINKING THAT STATE WILL TAKE
CARE OF IT THEY'LL BE MORE MONEY
AROUND THE CORNER THEY'RE NOT
GONNA.
WE HEARD OAKLAND MAYBE THERE'S
REPORT LIKE --
DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT THEY'LL
COME BACK AGAIN TO HELP US OUT
AGAIN JUST JUST --
WILL SOLVE THAT PROBLEM TOMORROW.
WHAT WHAT WHAT'S YOUR COUNSEL TO
TO THE THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THE MAYOR MAY NOT BE?
HAVING STRIKES OR MAY HAVE
CONTRACTS COMING UP AND THEY'RE
HAVING THE SAME DISCUSSIONS WHEN
THEY'RE BALANCING THEIR BUDGETS.
I'M CERTAINLY YOU KNOW BUDGETING
AT ANY LEVEL AS A MATTER OF
FOUND SEEN HERE DIFFERENT
PRIORITIES AND WE WOULD HOPE
THAT.
YOU KNOW AS THESE CONTRACTS ARE
BEING NEGOTIATED BUCKLEY THEY'RE
LOOKING AT THEIR AVAILABLE
RESOURCES I'M TAKING YOU KNOW
FUTURE BUDGET CONSTRAINTS INTO
CONSIDERATION AS THEIR
NEGOTIATING THOSE CONTRACTS --
I KNOW YOU'D MENTIONED OAKLAND --
IT TYPICALLY --
PROBABLY IN RELATION TO THE
ACTION THAT WAS TAKEN IN THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT --
WHERE WE ARE ANTICIPATING A
MARCH A FIRST REPORT THAT WAS
RECEIVED THIS LAST WEEK I'M IN
THE SPRING WILL HAVE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND --
THE INFORMATION THAT WAS
PROVIDED BY THICK MAT AND THE
COUNTY OFFICES IN THAT REPORT
AND WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE IN TERMS
OF ASSISTANCE THAT NEEDS TO BE
BUILT INTO THE BUDGET IN THE
SPRING PROCESS --
I WOULD ADD ONE MORE THING THAT
WE HAVEN'T REALLY TALKED ABOUT
YET AND CERTAINLY THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE ON ON THE RESOURCE
SIDE AND POTENTIAL.
ADDITIONAL SOURCES OF REVENUE
BOTH FOR THE STATE AND ALSO
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS --
IT'S CURRENTLY --
A CONVERSATION THAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT IS IS INTERESTED
IN IN BEGINNING TO HAVE WITH
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AND AND
STAKEHOLDERS --
THE AND AND YOU KNOW.
YEAH I I KNOW THERE ARE THERE IS
POTENTIAL MEASURES ON THE BALLOT
AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR IN THE
STATE OF THIS OR I THINK THE
GOVERNOR'S MANSION THE OTHER.
OTHER IDEAS AS WELL --
THE THERE I I THINK WE WE NEED
TO THINK VERY VERY BROADLY NOT
JUST [inaudible]
THE OLD.
HAVEN'T STATE REVENUE IDEAS BUT
ALSO WAYS THAT YOU KNOW THE
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES SYSTEM CAN
WORK MORE CLOSELY TOGETHER. TO
TO TO BRING DOWN MORE FEDERAL
FUNDING --
YELLED --
SOURCES THAT MAY NOT BE FULLY
UTILIZED AT THE MOMENT AT AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL SO I I THINK YOU
KNOW.
WE WILL DO OUR THE
SUPERINTENDENT CERTAINLY
ADVOCATE THAT THAT WE AS A STATE
HAVE A DISCUSSION OF A BROAD
DISCUSSION AROUND RESOURCES FOR
FOR EDUCATION AND REALLY
RESOURCES. FOR FOR CHILDREN IN
IN GENERAL.
THE DAILY I WANT.
TO JUMP IN ON WHAT SOME
DISTRICTS ARE.
GOING THROUGH RELATED TO THEIR
OBLIGATIONS THEIR CONTRACTS AND
HOW MUCH MONEY THE STATE HAS
GOING.
FOR YEAH I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
TOO MUCH TO ADD TO WHAT THE
SUPERINTENDENT ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ALREADY ADDED BUT I
THINK WE WOULD JUST REITERATE
ARE.
KIND OF UNDERSTANDING AT THIS
POINT THAT IF ANYTHING THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT BUDGET
MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT TIGHTER BY
MAY AND SO I THINK WE WANT TO
SEND A STEP.
MY DISTRICTS TO SORT OF
ENCOURAGE DISTRICTS NOT TO BE
TOO AMBITIOUS AND WITH THE
PLANNING FOR FOR THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU YES.
MR MESSAGING THANK YOU --
ITS SHARE AYE --
WANTED -- TO
ALSO WITH FEATURES INDULGENCE.
I JUST ASK A FEW QUICK FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS AND SPECIAL EDUCATION --
A AGAIN --
KUDOS TO LA --
FOR YOUR VERY HELPFUL CHARTS YOU
HAVE THIS CHART ON FIGURE TEN ON
PAGE SIXTEEN WHICH SHOWS THE
AREA.
THE GROWING SHARE OF CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS RECEIVING SPECIALIST
YOUR YOUR REPORT INDICATES THAT.
THAT THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
POPULATION HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
INCREASING OVER THE LAST TEN
YEARS.
YES -- AND
ALSO YOU YOU MAKE THE POINT IN
YOUR REPORT THAT --
THAT BECAUSE THE IN ROMAN HAS
BEEN DROPPING OVERALL A WHILE
THE THE EXPENSES A SPECIAL
EDUCATION HAS BEEN INCREASING --
SPECIALLY WITH THE GROWING
POPULATION OF THE HIGHLY
INTENSIVE --
NEEDS OR OR THEY STUDENTS
NEEDING HIGHLY INTENSIVE
SERVICES [inaudible]
THAT -- THE
GENERAL OF THE LOCAL GENERAL
FUND.
THE THE THE LOCAL GENERAL FUNDS --
HAVE BEEN COVERING AN INCREASING --
BECAUSE BARBER PORTION OF THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION COSTS IN THAT
HAS RISEN.
FROM ABOUT 45% OF THE GENERAL
LOCAL GENERAL FUNDS TEN YEARS
AGO TO NOW APPROACHING 60% --
IT IS IS THAT CORRECT THAT
THAT'S CORRECT SPECIAL EDUCATION
BE A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BETWEEN
THE STATE TO CATEGORICAL FUNDING
INTO DISTRICTS LOCAL GENERAL
FUNDS ABOUT WHAT'S CHANGED THE
PAST TEN YEARS AS THE RELATIVE
SHARE OF THOSE.
COSTS DATE.
TEN FEDERAL SHARE HAVEN'T BEEN
GOING MUCH FASTER THAN THE COST
OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT AND SO THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN HOW FAST COST
OF ACTUALLY GROWN IN.
KINDOF THOSE OTHER TWO SOURCES
HAS MEANT THAT DISTRICTS ARE
COVERING A LARGER AND LARGER
SHARE OF THEIR GENERAL OPERATING
BUDGETS GENERALLY THROUGH THE
HOUSE IF STUFF AND AND AND AND
THAT CERTAINLY THE THE REALITY
THAT -- THAT
MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS OF MY
DISTRICT ARE ARE ARE SHARING
WITH MANSA THAT I I'D LIKE TO
TURN TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
YOU KNOW MY AND MY THE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSING OF THAT --
THAT THERE BE --
THE TARGETED EDITION OF FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT ONLY
FOR THE DISTRICTS THAT HAVE.
THE THEY THEY THAT THEY RECEIVE
THE CONCENTRATION GRANTS FOR FOR
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE --
OF A 55% OR HIGHER AND
DUPLICATED STUDENTS TO THE IS IT
IS THAT CORRECT.
GOOD MORNING LISA RESIDENTS KICK
IN FIRST --
I'D LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION IS A HIGH
PRIORITY OF THE THE
ADMINISTRATION AS EVIDENCED BY
ITS INCLUSION OF THREE OR NINETY
MILLION ON GOING IN AND HUNDRED
SEVENTY SEVEN MILLION ONE TIME --
AND SO --
YOU KNOW WITH THAT CONVERSATION
IT IS RECOGNIZED THAT SPECIAL
EDUCATION IS AN AREA IN THE
STATE WHICH NEEDS SOME
ADDITIONAL FOCUS.
SO -- AND
I'M SORRY COULD YOU REPEAT THE
QUESTION NOW --
MIKE MIKE THE QUESTION IS --
IT IS A CORRECT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION RIGHT NOW IS ONLY
PROPOSING ADDITIONAL FUNDING
ONLY FOR THE DISTRICTS SERVING
LARGE -- THE
V. I. ON THAT THE THE DISTRICTS
WITHOUT WITHOUT --
HI UNDER TO GET A STUDENT COUNTS.
YES THANK YOU YES THAT IS THE
WAY IT THAT THE FORMULA IS
DESIGNED FOR HIGH END DUPLICATED
IN HIGH AA --
ABOVE AVERAGE SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS SO IT'S MORE OF A
TARGETED INVESTMENT WHERE WE
BELIEVE THERE'S HIGHER NEED --
AND HIGHER RISK OF BECOMING
SPECIAL EDUCATION IDENTIFIED BUT
YOU KNOW MY MY CONCERN IS THAT
THERE ARE DISTRICTS --
THE THE VAST MAJORITY OF AT
LEAST IN TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE --
DATA THE FIGHT YOU KNOW BECAUSE
THEY THEY THEY MAY NOT HAVE THE
THE HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF THE
LOW INCOME FOSTER KIDS AND
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS BUT
STILL THEY HAVE.
A HIGH POPULATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION STUDENTS.
THERE'S THERE'D THE OB
STRUGGLING ALSO YOU KNOW THEY'RE
GOOD THEY'RE DEALING WITH THAT
SAME REALITY OF OF LARGER LARGER
PORTIONS OF THEIR GENERAL FUND --
HAVING TO COVER THE SHORTFALL
THAT IF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
SHORTFALL IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
COSTS AND SO.
YEAH I I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THE GOVERNOR IS NOT RECOGNIZING
THE REALITY THAT.
TO THAT THE DISTRICTS WHO --
WITH THE LOWER UNTYPED ON
DUPLICATE STATE ACCOUNTS BUT
STILL FACE --
SPECIAL EDUCATION CHALLENGES WHY
ARE THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL IS
NOT TRYING TO HELP THEM OUT ALSO.
IT I AND IN THIS INVESTMENT IS
RELEASED.
AB TARGETED AND KIND OF
STRATEGIC REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
FOCUS -- THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA IS
REALLY --
IT'S A FORMULA FOR ALL STUDENTS
GENERAL EDUCATION AND SPECIAL
EDUCATION TO THE EXTENT THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION NEED AT
STUDENT NEED SERVICES AND
SUPPORTS THAT DRAW ON THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA.
IT'S THEIR DOLLARS WELL SO I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND WE'VE SEEN TWENTY THREE
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASES AND
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA
SINCE SINCE INCEPTION.
SO ALL DISTRICT SHOULD HAVE BEEN
SEEN INCREASES IN FUNDING.
AND THAT SHOULD BE USED ON THEIR
SPECIAL EDUCATION STUDENTS AS
WELL IBM BUT I YOU KNOW WANT TO
REMIND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THAT -- YOU
KNOW FOR EXAMPLE WHILE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT --
THE PER PEOPLE --
STUDENTS SPENDING GOING UP TO
TWELVE THOUSAND PER STUDENT I
KNOW THAT --
THAT -- SOME
OF MY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN IN IN
MY DISTRICT ARE RECEIVING ON
AVERAGE ABOUT --
EIGHT THOUSAND FUNDING PER
STUDENT AND SO WHILE THE BE --
THE THE THE INCREASES HAVE HAVE
BEEN THE MOST DRAMATIC WITH THE
WITH THE SCHOOL DISTRICT THE
HAVE IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S THE THE
ALSO ALL DISTRICTS ARE ARE ARE
ARE STRUGGLING AND AND SO IT'S
IT'S NOT IT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE
THAT.
TO THAT --
YOU KNOW ALL OF YOU KNOW ALL
DISTRICTS HAVE RECEIVED
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FUNDING AND I
I WOULD JUST ASK THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE -- TO
TO TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION
THAT ALL SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
ARE STRUGGLING WITH --
DRAMATICALLY INCREASING SPECIAL
EDUCATION COSTS WE'VE HEARD
THOSE CONCERNS AS WELL AND WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO
TAKE THOSE CONCERNS BACK WITH US.
THANK YOU I WENT TO BEFORE WE GO
ON TO THE NEXT PART WITH OUR
SUPERINTENDENTS REPRESENTATIVE.
TALK ABOUTTHE EARLY EDUCATION
COMPONENT WE'RE GONNA HAVE A BIG
HEARING ABOUT THIS A FEW WEEKS
AND WE HAD A SPECIAL HEARING A
FEW WEEKS AGO ON ON PRE K. FOR
ALL AND WHAT IT WOULD TAKE YOUR
CALIFORNIA SO.
OBVIOUSLY IT I'M A BIG BELIEVER
THAT C. MATTERS AND CERTAINLY
PLEASED TO SEE THAT.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
STEPPING UP TO INVEST IN OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS AND WANTED TO
TO REALLY ASK THE LA ABOUT YOUR
RECOMMENDATION.
THAT AS FAR AS THAT THE PRE K.
FOR ALL EXPANSION YOU.
YOU -- MAYBE.
SUGGEST THAT WE TAKE A STEP BACK
BECAUSE THERE'S SOME COME
CAPACITY ISSUES AND SO LOGISTICS
ISSUES SO.
THE FLIP SIDE IS MAYBE WE SHOULD
LOOK AT THOSE CAPACITY ISSUES
AND FACILITIES AND WORK FORCE --
AS A WAY TO TURN TO WRAP UP AS
OPPOSED TO NOT RAMP UP BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T ADDRESSED IT KIND OF
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN.
SO DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT IN
YOUR ANALYSIS.
YES WE WE DID THINK ABOUT THAT
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PERHAPS A
PROPOSAL FOR WORK FORCE AND
FACILITY --
FACILITY GRANTS OF BOOK.
BUT AS WE LOOKED AT THOSE
SPECIFIC PROPOSALS WE HAD
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LACK OF
TARGETING ON THOSE PER THE
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO TARGET
THOSE PROPOSALS FOR SPECIFIC
ISSUES AND ALL PROVIDE ONE
EXAMPLE HERE --
THE FOR THE THE FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SPECIFICALLY --
I THINK WE ARE WE THINK THAT THE
STATE LACKS SOME DATA ON
WORKFORCE UP ON SOME BASIC DATA
ON WORKFORCE ISSUES SUCH AS THE
NUMBER OF TEACHERS IN THE STATE
OR THE NUMBER OF TEACHERS IN
SPECIFIC REGIONS --
AND IT WOULD BE REALLY DIFFICULT
FOR THE STATE TO PROVIDE FUNDS --
SPECIFICALLY TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF TEACHERS --
IN THE WORK FORCE.
WITHOUT HAVING A SET TARGET GOT
A NUMBER ABOUT THE SLOTS SO YOU
RECOMMEND NOT INCREASING.
THE EN THOUSAND FEET WE DO
WELCOME TWO THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED A NEW SLOT INCREASES AND
ALSO STARTING THOSE INCREASES
MID YEAR I'M PARTICULARLY
BECAUSE THE SLIGHT INCREASE THE
GOVERNOR PROPOSES --
IS A TEN THOUSAND INCREASE WHICH
IS ABOUT 40% OF THE NON ELLIE A
FULL DAY SLOTS OVER ONE YEAR AND
WE THINK THAT MIGHT BE QUITE
CHALLENGING.
I'M GIVEN SOME LOGISTICAL TERM --
CAN LOGISTICAL CONCERNS ON THE
ADMINISTRATION SIDE AS WELL ON
AS A PROVIDER SITES A LOCALLY AT
THE STATE LEVEL.
OKAY WE OBVIOUSLY DISAGREE THAT
THAT'S WHY WE'LL HAVE OUR
HEARINGS THROUGHOUT THE THE
SPRING TO IRON THIS OUT SO WITH
THAT LET'S.
PROCEED WITH OUR NEXT --
SECTION OF THE AGENDA AND
THEY'LL GET TO PUBLIC COMMENTS
REALLY TO INVITE UP LUPITA
CORTEZ AKULA.
OUR NEW --
DEPUTY SUPERINTENDENT FOR PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION TO SEE THAT
CALIFORNIA.
AND SUPER EXCITED TO WELCOME YOU
IN YOUR NEW CAPACITY.
I KNOW YOU'RE HEARING YOUR
HIGHER ED WHERE ALL THE LAST FEW
YEARS AND AGAIN --
YOU KNOW WE'RE EXCITED TO SEE
HAVE YOU SERVE.
THE KIDS A CALIFORNIA AND I KNOW
YOU'RE MAKING A LOT OF PEOPLE
PROUD OF BEING THE FIRST LATINA
EVER TO HAVE THIS POSITION IN
THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO.
CONGRATULATIONS AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US HERE
THIS MORNING THANK YOU SO MUCH
AS A PLEASURE FOR ME TO BE HERE --
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
SPEAK.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND --
HE WAS UNABLE TO BE HERE TODAY
AND SO I AM HERE WITH YOU --
WE HERE I HAVE A HAND OUT THAT
I'M SUPPOSED TO DO NOT FORGET TO
SEND TO PROVIDE YOU --
SO YOU CAN FOLLOW ALONG I WILL
BE BRIEF --
THERE'S FIVE MAIN --
PRIORITIES I WANTED TO OUTLINED
FOR YOU TODAY FIRST OF ALL --
YOU KNOW THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR.
OF FOR HIS ATTENTION AND
COMMITMENT TO EDUCATION IN HIS
BUDGET.
WE HAVE AN UNPRECEDENTED
OPPORTUNITY TO DO MORE WITH MORE --
SO WE'RE EXCITED TO BUILD ON A
COMPREHENSIVE EDUCATION SYSTEM
THAT SERVES ALL CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES PREPARING CALIFORNIA TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF COMMUNITIES IN
THE WORK FORCE FOR THE TWENTY
FIRST.
CENTURY AND BEYOND SO WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR FOR
PLACING A TOP PRIORITY ON
EDUCATION AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
A REALLY STRONG --
PRODUCTIVE PARTNERSHIP WITH HIM
IN THE LEGISLATURE IN OF COURSE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE NEXT FEW
YEARS THAT WILL LIFT ALL OUR
STUDENTS --
BY IMPROVING OUR EDUCATION
SYSTEM AND INCREASING THE
RESOURCES TO OUR SCHOOLS.
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO YOU CHAIR
FOR YOUR STATION ON MEETING THE
NEEDS OF THE EARLIEST LEARNERS.
EARLY EDUCATION IS A OBVIOUSLY A
CRITICAL STEP IN THE OPPORTUNITY
AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
IS WE KNOW THAT 90% OF BRAIN
DEVELOPMENT OCCURS BEFORE THE
AGE OF FIVE IT'S SO IMPORTANT
ARE EDUCATION RESOURCES PROMOTE
A HEALTHY START FOR OUR CHILDREN.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHERE THEY LIVE.
SO IN ADDITION TO EARLY
EDUCATION ONE OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS --
PRIORITIES IS HIGH QUALITY
SCHOOLS THAT BETTER EQUIPPED TO
SERVICE TO ALL STUDENTS AND THIS
IS KNOWN AS COMMUNITY SCHOOLS
AND THAT'S A ON ON YOUR HAND OUT.
THE SCHOOL TO WORK WITH THEIR
COUNTIES AND LOCAL PARTNERS
WORKING TOGETHER TO ADDRESS THE
VERY REAL NEEDS OF STUDENTS AND
THEIR FAMILIES IN FACT.
SUPERINTENDENT THURMAN IS
SPONSORING LEGISLATION AB ELEVEN
NINETY SIX ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON
TO CREATE COMMUNITY SCHOOLS.
SOMETHING YOU TOUCHED ON EARLIER
WITH REGARD TO THE STRIKES WELL
THE STRIKES IS NOT ALL ABOUT THE
RACES IT'S ABOUT THE STUDENTS
SUPPORTS.
IN THE SCHOOLS THE LIBRARIANS A
PSYCHOLOGIST THE NURSES AND SO
THIS -- THIS
EFFORT.
IN ATTEMPTS TO TO TO HELP
MITIGATE SOME OF THAT AND
PROVIDE RESOURCES TO THE SCHOOLS
AND TEACHERS --
IN COMMUNITIES THAT REALLY
NEEDED SO WE WANT TO CREATE
THESE MEANINGFUL STRUCTURES AND
STRATEGIES IN RELATIONSHIPS.
AND LEARNING CONDITIONS AN
OPPORTUNITY SAYS AND SUPPORT
THAT MIGHT NOT OTHERWISE BE
AVAILABLE --
BOTH IN AND OUT OF SCHOOL.
THE SCHOOLS WILL USE THIS
INTEGRATED APPROACH TO INCREASE
ACCESS TO BUT I MENTIONED
EARLIER THE NURSES COUNSELORS
SOCIAL WORKERS AND CREATING
PLACES WHERE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES HAVE --
HAVE EASY ACCESS TO SERVICES
NEEDED TO CLOSE THOSE
OPPORTUNITY AND ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
PROVIDING THE SUPPORT WILL HELP
PERSON BE READY AND ABLE TO MEET
THE ACADEMIC OPPORTUNITIES
PRESENTED TO THEM IN CLASS
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP
REQUIRES ACCESS TO WORLD CLASS
INSTRUCTION AND TOOLS INCLUDED.
INCLUDING ACCESS TO STEAM AND
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION WHICH
IS ANOTHER BIG PRIORITY OF THE
SUPERINTENDENTS.
SO OUR TEACHERS INCLUDING THOSE
THAT ARE WORKING WITH OUR
YOUNGEST LEARNERS CANNOT BE
EXPECTED TO DO IT ALONE.
WE NEED TO PROVIDE HIGH QUALITY
EVIDENCE AND PRACTICE BASED
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE THE TOOLS
AND THE TRAINING NEEDED TO MAKE
SURE ALL STUDENTS ARE READING BY
THE THIRD GRADE.
WHICH BRINGS ME TO A VERY
IMPORTANT PASSION OF OUR
SUPERINTENDENT THAT LITERACY.
IT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO THE ACADEMIC
AND LIFE SUCCESSES OFTEN SAID
YOU KNOW IT IF WE CAN IMPROVE
LITERACY AMONGST OUR EARLIEST
LEARNERS --
WE CAN HELP SOLVE THE PRESENT
YOU KNOW THAT SCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE.
WE NEED TO ENGAGE OUR FAMILIES
AND COMMUNITIES CREATE A CULTURE
OF LITERACY IN READING THAT
INSTILLED A LOVE OF LIFELONG
LEARNING TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
THE CAREER TO THE TWENTY FIRST
CENTURY.
THE SPEAKING OF EMPOWERING
COMMUNITIES YOU TOUCHED ON THIS
A LITTLE EARLIER TODAY.
SO WE CAN EXPECT TEACHERS TO
TEACH HIGH QUALITY TEACHERS
TEACH IN AREAS THAT THEY CAN'T
AFFORD TO LIVE IN.
SO ONE OTHER MAJOR PRIORITY IS
THE A WORK FORCE HOUSING SO OUR
EDUCATORS CAN LIVE IN THE
COMMUNITIES EIGHT WHERE THEY
WORK.
IT'S VITAL FOR OUR DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND COUNTY
OFFICES TO RECOUP THE BEST AND
BRIGHTEST TEACHERS FOR OUR
STUDENTS SO WE NEED TO INVEST IN
OUR TEACHERS.
THEY WILL BE ABLE THEN TO INVEST
IN EATING OUR TEACHERS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COMMUNITIES THEY TEACH AND THEY
CAN TAKE THEIR TWO HOURS OF
COMMUTE TIME AND INVEST THAT
TIME BUILDING STRONGER
CONNECTIONS IN THE COMMUNITY
SERVER.
WE NEED TO CONTINUE TO IMPROVE
THE WORKING CONDITIONS OF OUR
EDUCATORS THEY DESERVE BETTER
AND OUR STUDENTS DESERVE BETTER
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT.
TONY THURMAN AND CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU.
IN THE MONTHS AHEAD TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE MAKE THE MOST OF THIS
UNPRECEDENTED OPPORTUNITY.
BUILDING A COMPREHENSIVE
EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT SERVES ALL
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
MEETING THEM IN THE COMMUNITIES
THEY LIVE IN.
AND PREPARING OUR STUDENTS FOR
HIGHER EDUCATION AND THE TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY WORKFORCE AGAIN
OUR PRIORITIES ARE COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS.
EARLY LEARNING LITERACY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
WORK FORCE HOUSING.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU PERFECT THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
WITH THAT WE'LL --
BEGIN NOW WITH PUBLIC COMMENTS.
YOU PLEASE LINE UP IN THE CENTER
RIGHT THERE.
IF YOU TRY TO KEEP YOUR COMMENT
TO ONE MINUTE OR LESS. ONE
MINUTE OR LESS THANK YOU.
DINI MICHELETTI COLBERN REPLICAS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE HEARING
TODAY A COUPLE COMMENTS WE
SUPPORT THE FLEXIBILITY FOR
CONTRACTORS THAT OPERATE MANY
DIFFERENT CONTRACT TYPES --
WE HAVE A BIT OF CONCERN ON THE
FACILITY GRANTS --
WE ABSOLUTELY BELIEVE THAT THE
PRIVATE SIDE OF THE MIX DELIVERY
SYSTEM HAS THE CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT MORE SPACES.
BUT WE HAVE A VERY BURDENSOME
PROCUREMENT PROCESS WAS CD'S SO
WE'RE CONCERNED IN THE TIME
LINES TO GET THE MONEY AND THE
FACILITIES THAT BUILT.
WE SUPPORT --
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT --
WE APPRECIATE THE CASELOAD
ADJUSTMENT.
WHAT WE DO KNOW IS WITH TWELVE
MONTH ELIGIBILITY THE FAMILIES
ARE STAYING SO THAT'S A GOOD
THING?
THE COLA --
WE HOPE THAT THAT AS WE GO ALONG
MORE MONIES ALLOCATED FOR
VOUCHERS THERE ARE FEWER THAN A
THOUSAND SLOTS THAT WERE
ALLOCATED --
AND FINALLY YOU ONE THING ON THE
WORK GETTING MORE PROVIDER TYPES
IS SYNONYMOUS WITH THAT WE GOT
TO PAY THE PROVIDERS.
WHAT THEY THINK THAT THEY ARE
WHEN PROVIDERS AND CENTERS THIS
INCLUDES CENTERS ALSO?
MANY OF THE SUBSIDIZE SIDE OF
THE MARKET USE VARIABLE WORK
SCHEDULES WE ONLY PAY THE
PROVIDERS BASED ON THE ACTUAL
USE SO PROVIDER WHO HAS A FULL
TIME OR PART TIME SPOT HELD FOR
A FAMILY.
WE DON'T PAY THEM WHAT THEY
EXPECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY THOUGHT WHAT'S
ON BEHALF OF ACCESS ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS WE HAVE OUR
BUDGET LETTER.
JUST MENTION A COUPLE OF
HIGHLIGHTS THE FIRST THANK YOU
TO BOTH OF YOU AND OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR TALKING
ABOUT THE NEED FOR MORE FUNDING
FOR EDUCATION.
AB YOU SPOKE FOR WHAT YOU SEE ON
THE IN AND OUT OF THE NEWS
HEADLINES AND SO WE APPRECIATE
THE RECOGNITION FOR MORE FUNDING --
ACCESS APPRECIATIVE TO THE
GOVERNOR FOR THE FUNDING
INCREASES TO WELL CFF TO PROVIDE
THE COLA.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THAT THREE
BILLION ONE TIME INVESTMENT FROM
THE GENERAL FUND FOR THE PENSION
RELIEF FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
AS WELL AS A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE FACILITY --
ALLOCATION FOR THE STATE --
STATE BOND WITH THAT SAID --
WELL WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE
AND SUPPORTIVE OF MORE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION WE BELIEVE
THAT WE NEED TO THINK MORE
COMPREHENSIVELY ABOUT EQUALIZING
SPECIAL ED RATES --
SIMILAR TO I'M FROM ART TO
CHEESE COMMENTS ABOUT THAT
DISTRIBUTION METHOD WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE INEQUITIES
HE WOULD PROVIDE BY AND
PRIORITIZING FUNDING ON SCHOOL
DISTRICT AT THE HIGHER END OF
THE KID ACCOUNTS AS WELL AS
THOSE WITH A HIGHER PERCENTAGE
OF THAT SPECIAL ED STUDENTS.
WE LIVE EVERYONE HAS A SPECIAL
EDUCATION RATES GOING UP --
SO THAT'S ONE AREA THAT WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE WE'RE SUPPORTING OF THE
FUNDING WE LOOK FOR TO THE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE COMING
YEAR.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AND STAFF JEFF AKA REPRESENTING
THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS --
WE BELIEVE THERE'S A LOT TO LIKE
IN THIS YEAR'S PROPOSED BUDGET --
WE APPLAUD THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE ONGOING COMMITMENT TO
PROVIDING FUNDING TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. FOR
ALSO APPLAUDING THE INVESTMENT
IN SPECIAL EDUCATION BUT WE DO
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU RAISED MISTER MURATSUCHI
WITH REGARD TO THE ALLOCATION
METHOD.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE ADMINISTRATIONAND YOUR
SUB COMMITTEE --
TO DISCUSS THOSE --
DISCUSS THAT STRUCTURE FURTHER.
AND THEN MISTER CHAIR I THINK
YOU HAVE ACCURATELY IDENTIFIED
THE CONUNDRUM THAT MANY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND THE STATE ARE
FACING RIGHT NOW.
HOW DO WE BALANCE THE DESIRE TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH THE
RESOURCES AND PROVIDE EMPLOYEES --
WITH A LIVING WAGE AND MANY
CASES.
HOW DO WE BALANCE THAT AGAINST
THE CAPACITY OF EACH INDIVIDUAL
SCHOOL DISTRICT?
THAT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT
LEVEL OF I BELIEVE IT'S NEXT
WEEK FROM --
MIGHT FIND AFFECT MATT IS GOING
TO BE REALLY IMPORTANT IN TERMS
OF UNDERSTANDING MANY OF THE
FISCAL PRESSURES THAT ARE BEING
FACED BY SCHOOL DISTRICTS --
AND HOW THOSE COULD BE
EXACERBATED --
IF REVENUES WERE TO DECREASE AS
WAS SUGGESTED MIGHT BE A
POSSIBILITY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS NANCY TRIED
AS A SPIN OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE SCHOOL
HOUSING GOOD MORNING --
THE CONVERSATION THE COMMITTEES
ENGAGING IN ABOUT HOW TO HOW --
TO IMPROVING EXPAND SERVICES TO
OUR STUDENTS IT'S VERY
ENCOURAGING CASH WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND YOU THAT --
OUR EDUCATORS AND STAFF NEED THE
ADEQUATE FACILITIES IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE ALL OF THOSE SERVICES SO
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO SELL ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION AND PROFIT TO ONE BONDS
WE ALSO SUPPORT THE ONE POINT
TWO MILLION ALLOCATION TO THE
OFFICE OF PUBLIC SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION.
TO EXPEDITE THE PROCESSING
HOWEVER CASH WILL BE COMING BACK
TO WIN FACILITIES ARE AN AGENDA
AS DIED --
TO SUGGEST SOME OTHER WAYS THAT
WE CAN FURTHER EXPEDITE THE THE
APPROPRIATION OF THOSE FUNDS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANKS VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WE LIKE
TO FIRST THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR PROPOSING IN
THE GOVERNOR FOR PROPOSING A
VERY POSITIVE --
BUDGET FOR PUBLIC EDUCATION --
FOR THIS YEAR --
WE'RE OVERALL PLEASE --
PARTICULARLY --
HAPPY ABOUT THE TWO BILLION IN
COLA FOR SCHOOLS --
THE THREE BILLION FOR CAL STIRS
PAYMENT WE'RE STILL ANALYZING
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD PIECE WE
WOULD SUPPORT --
MORE EXPANSION --
VERSUS THE LA --
AND PAIRING THAT DOWN WE WOULD
SUPPORT.
INCREASE IN TEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL SLOTS --
WE DO HAVE CONCERNS SIMILAR TO
YOURS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
MURATSUCHI RELATED TO THE
SPECIAL EDUCATION DISTRIBUTION
MODEL -- ALL
OF OUR DISTRICTS ARE SEEING
INCREASES IN SPECIAL EDUCATION
YET THIS PROPOSAL ONLY PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO SOME OF
THOSE DISTRICTS --
WE DO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION IN A FACILITIES AS WELL --
IT WAS AN INTERESTING
CONVERSATION ABOUT SB GRAY THE
SIX IN TERMS OF PER PUPIL
FUNDING -- I
WOULD --
WOULD ARGUE AGAINST THE LA --
IN TERMS OF TWENTY THIRD I THINK
WE STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
WE'RE STILL LAST IN THE COUNTRY
AND NURSES AND COUNSELORS AND
AND DOT LIBRARIAN TODAY SO WE
HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO AND THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTY FOR
YOUR WORK.
AROUND THIS --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CENTER BORRERO ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION.
A CSA SUPPORTS THE OVERALL
FRAMEWORK OFTHE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSAL I'D LIKE TO
SPECIFICALLY COMMENT ON THE
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS.
FOR EARLY LEARNING PROFESSIONALS
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
GRANDFATHER EXISTING STAFF AND
TO PAY FOR ANY NEW TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS THESE ARE OFTEN LOW
WAGE POSITIONS AND CSEA WOULD.
OPPOSE ANY PROPOSAL THAT WOULD
INCREASE EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT PROVIDING RESOURCES TO
EXISTING STAFF THANK YOU.
ELIZABETH ASK ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE DO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S INVESTMENT IN THE
LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA --
WE WANT --
TO CAST WILL ALSO EXPRESSES THE
SAME CONCERNS THAT MAYOR TO T.
EXPRESS ON THE SPECIAL EDUCATION
FUNDING WE APPRECIATE THE THE
FUNDING FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
ATTENTION BECAUSE IT'S LONG
NEEDED.
BUT WE WANT TO SEE THAT THE
FUNDING A DIFFERENT MODIFIED
DISTRIBUTION METHOD AND WE WANT
TO SEETHAT FUNDS GOING TO AB
SIX OH TWO FUNDING INSTEAD.
I WE DO APPRECIATE THE ONE POINT
FIVE BILLION FACILITIES BUT WE
WANT -- TO
TO THE ADMINISTRATION THE
LEGISLATURE TO FUND THE
REMAINING WORK LOW LIST ON THE
BUDGET YEAR TO EXPEDITE THE
PROJECT'S AWAITING RESOURCES WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT IT'S
GOING TO BE --
MAKING A PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR CAL STARS
AND THE ONE POINT FOUR BILLION
ON EARLY EDUCATION THANK YOU.
MORNING MR CHAIR MEMBER OF MARK
THE GUERRERO REPRESENTED THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
AND ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WE APPLAUD THE
GOVERNOR'S BALL SET OF
INITIATIVES FOR IMPROVING CHILD
WILL BE IN AND STRENGTHENING
FAMILIES --
INCLUDING HIS PROPOSED
INVESTMENTS TO BUILD CAPACITY OF
THE EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
SYSTEM SUCH AS THE UNIVERSAL
PRESCHOOL.
AND BOLSTER OTHER ESSENTIAL
SUPPORT SERVICES.
INCLUDING HIS COMMITMENT TO
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS WITH
GRANTS FACILITY DEVELOPMENT TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SERVICES FOR CHILDREN
BIRTH TO FIVE YEARS OLD.
WITH GRANTS DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
THE PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT OF
EARLY EDUCATORS WHICH HAS BEEN
VERY HELPFUL FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY.
WE ALSO REQUEST ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS IN EARLY CARE AND
EDUCATION SERVICES THAT MEET THE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES WHICH INCLUDES.
SIX ART --
NEED -- TO
ADDRESS SIGNIFICANT --
SUPPORT FOR INFANTS AND TODDLERS
IN A REPORT RELEASED BY THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT ONLY 6% OF
BABIES AND TODDLERS OF INCOME
ELIGIBLE FAMILIES ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS STATE SUBSIDIZED SERVICES
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
INDENTATION --
WE REQUEST THE REFORM OF THE
BIFURCATED REIMBURSEMENT RATES
SYSTEM TO A STREAMLINED SYSTEM
TO MEET THE TRUE COST OF
OPERATING QUALITY PROGRAMS
INCLUDING THE EQUITABLE
COMPENSATION.
OVERLY EDUCATORS COMPARABLE TO
THEIR EDUCATION AND EXPERIENCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR TAKING
THE TIME.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION --
WANTED IT WE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION THAT
THIS COMMITTEE IS HAVING ABOUT
THE SYSTEMIC UNDER FUNDING OF
EDUCATION AND WE'D LIKE TO
ASSOCIATE OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE.
I KNOW WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE
OF THE GOVERNOR'S FIRST STEP IN
THE BUDGET HIS COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATION WE SUPPORT COLA --
WE APPRECIATE THE CONVERSATION
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S HAVING
REGARD TO SPECIAL ED IN SUPPORT
EFFORTS TO HELP DISTRICTS THAT
DO HAVE A DISPROPORTIONATE
NUMBER WE ALSO SUPPORT
EQUALIZATION OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION AND THINK THAT WE
MIGHT BE ABLE TO FIND.
A LONG TERM SOLUTION TOWARDS
TAKING STEPS --
SPECIAL AND SYSTEMICALLY AND WE
ALSO SUPPORT THAT GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL REGARD TO CAL STIRS --
WE WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE MANY
CREATIVE CONVERSATIONS THAT NEED
TO TAKE PLACE TO INSURE THAT
WERE NOT SIPHONING OFF FUNDS
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO PROP.
NINETY EIGHT AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA SO WE
WOULD ENCOURAGE THIS COMMITTEE
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE TO LOOK
AT WAYS THAT FUNDS WOULD BE
SIPHONED OFF OR OTHER WAYS THAT
WE CAN BRING IN ADDITIONAL FUNDS
SUCH AS FEDERAL TAX CONFORMITY.
AND RE EVALUATING --
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WHEN IT COMES TO TAX CREDITS AND
OTHER METHODS --
THAT WE USED TO SHARE FUNDS THAT
WOULD OTHERWISE GO TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
CONVERSATIONS ARE HAPPENING IN
OTHER COMMITTEES.
THAT WOULD IMPACT FUNDS THAT GO
TO PROP NINETY EIGHT THAT YOU
MAKE IT A POINT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU UNDERSTAND THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND THAT THEY'RE
INTEGRATED INTO LONG TERM
DISCUSSIONS OF EDUCATION FUNDING
THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING AND A GARAGE WITH
THE LOS ANGELES UNIFIED DISTRICT
I AND I JUST WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT. TO SAY THAT LAUSD
APPRECIATES THE DIRECTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET --
INCLUDING SPECIAL EDUCATION
THAT'S A PROPOSAL THAT WE
SUPPORT I AND WE ALSO THINK ON
MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER
MURATSUCHI FOR THE DISCUSSION ON
ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
I LAUSD CERTAINLY SUPPORTS THE
NEED -- TO
MAKE ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS HIM
FINALLY ON SPECIAL EDUCATION WE
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE --
LOOKING AT THREE CREEK THREE KEY
KITE CRITERIA WHICH IS WHETHER
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IS TARGETED
IS THE BASED ON NEED.
I AND ARE WE GOING TO IMPROVE
STUDENT.
GOOD MORNING CATHERINE OCCUR
GOING ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION COALITION WE
ARE EXCITED BY THE BOLD
INITIATIVES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL THAT
PRIORITIZE OUR STATE'S YOUNGEST
CHILDREN AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION TO FURTHER SHAPE
THESE PROPOSALS.
PARTICULARLY I WOULD LIKE TO
ECHO THE PREVIOUS COMMENTS ABOUT
ADDRESSING THIS AT THE STATE'S
BIFURCATED EAZY E. RATE SYSTEM.
THIS YEAR TO CREATE A SINGLE
REGIONAL LIES REIMBURSEMENT RATE
SYSTEM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR ON YOUR
BILL AB ONE TWENTY FIVE AS WELL
AS THE COMPANION LEGISLATION ON
THE SENATE SIDE.
SENATOR LEAVE A SUB SB ONE
SEVENTY FOUR ON THIS ISSUE.
WE WILL ALSO --
LIKE TO APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR --
FOR PROVIDING ADDITIONAL SPACES
FOR FOUR YEAR OLDS HOWEVER THERE
CONTINUES TO BE AN ACUTE
SHORTAGE OF CARE FIRST THE
STATE'S INS INFANTS AND TODDLERS.
WE REQUEST THAT YOU CONSIDER AB
ONE NINETY FOUR CARRIED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS TO INVEST
ONE BILLION OVER THREE YEARS TO
CREATE ADDITIONAL SPACES FOR
CHILDREN.
ZERO THREE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CERRILLOS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF TEACH PLUS
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
OUR TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN TEACHING POLICY FELLOWS
WERE CUSTOM EDUCATORS FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ALSO PART OF THE LCF EQUITY
COALITION --
IN OUR TEACHERS ARE REALLY IT'S
IT'S BEEN A VERY INTERESTING
YEAR AS THEY'VE LEARNED THEIR
FEELING VERY CONFIDENT AND AN
APPRECIATIVE OF THE FOUNDATION
THAT WE FELT THAT YOU ALL HAVE
BUILT OVER THE LAST EIGHT YEARS --
TO FOR ENSURING THAT EVERY
STUDENT HAS AN EQUAL OPPORTUNITY
TO LEARN AND APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR IDENTIFYING --
WHERE THERE ARE GAPS AND NEEDS --
TO TO TO CONTINUE TO TO LOOK AT
WHAT WE'RE THAT DREAM --
AND NAMELY WHEN IT COMES TO
SPECIAL EDUCATION IN THE
CONVERSATION YOU'RE HAVING ABOUT
ABOUT FUNDING IN GENERAL --
BUT A COUPLE OF KEY PIECES --
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL AROUND
DATA INFRASTRUCTURE IS ONE THAT
REALLY RESONATES WITH OUR
TEACHERS FOR NOT ABLE TO ANSWER
THE KEY QUESTIONS WE NEED TO
KNOW ABOUT --
HOW OUR STUDENTS ARE DOING OUR
SYSTEMS FUNCTIONING AND EVEN
MORE BROADLY HOW ARE TEACHER
WORKFORCE LOOKS AND HEALTH
INVESTMENTS IN OUR TEACHER
WORKFORCE ARE PLAYING OUT?
THEY WERE THEY WERE NOT DOING
OUR JOB AS AS STATE POLICYMAKERS
ENSURING EVERY STUDENT HAS AN
EQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN --
THEY'VE ALSO IDENTIFY JUST IN A
LETTER --
THREE AREAS WHERE WE FEEL LIKE
THE STATE HAS --
OUT HAS LAID OUT A POLICY
FRAMEWORK FOR REALLY FOR THAT
THEY'RE EXCITED ABOUT BUT HASN'T.
HASN'T MADE INITIAL INVESTMENT
TO ENSURE THAT SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS ARE ABLE TO TO MEET
THAT POLICY FRAMEWORKS IN NAMELY.
LOOKING AT THE L. ROADMAP TO
REALLY WHICH IS AN INCREDIBLE
PIECE OF POLICY BUT WE HAVEN'T.
REALLY --
FOR SUPPORTED IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO IMPLEMENT IT --
LOOKING AT OUR TEACHER AND THEN
LOOKING AT REALLY --
EDUCATOR LEARNING AND GROWTH --
BEFORE SERIOUS ABOUT CONTINUOUS
IMPROVEMENT TEACHERS NEED TO BE
LEADING THAT WE NEED TO SUPPORT
BUILDER CAPACITY TO DO THAT SO
WHETHER COMES TO OUR AND ARE
REALLY STRONG INDUCTION
STANDARDS OR R. II OR THE
EXPECTATIONS IN THEL. ROADMAP.
FOR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AS
A STATE WE NEED TO SEND THE
SIGNAL THAT SCHOOLS AND
DISTRICTS SHOULD BE INVESTING IN
THAT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING A CHAIR NUMBERS
WHISKEY AND WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES OF WE ARE ALSO PART OF
THE LCF EQUITY COALITION --
WE DEFINITELY SUPPORT AND
APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION IN THE
PRIORITIES IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S EDUCATION.
OF BUDGET --
AND WE APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE
CONVERSATION YOU HAD THIS
MORNING AND WE HOPE YOU'LL
CONTINUE IT TO FIGHT FOR MORE
THAN --
NINETY EIGHT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE OTHER PRIORITIES IN
THE OVERALL BUDGET --
IN K. TWELVE THE WHATEVER A
RANKING WE HAVE --
IT IS -- IT
IS PROBLEMATIC THAT --
THE RATIO OF ADULTS TO SINCE.
IN THE NATION N. FOR WHAT EVER
RANKING THAT WE HAVE --
AN ISSUE THAT IS STILL NOT FULLY
ADDRESSED IS THE FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY ISSUE.
THE BILLIONS THAT STUDENTS ARE
THE NEEDIEST STUDENTS HAVE
GENERATED.
OF STILL CANNOT BE FOLLOWED AS
TO WHETHER OR NOT INCREASE OUR
IMPROVEMENTS WERE ACTUALLY MADE
EVEN AFTER THEY UP PLANS WERE
MADE TO DO SO --
WE BELIEVE THAT OF TRANSPARENCY
IS REALLY HAMPERING OUR
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT --
WORK -- IN
THE UP IN THAT.
DISCUSSION AROUND --
FISCAL OF FISCAL DISTRESS THAT
DISTRICTS ARE FACING AND THEIR
BATTLES WITH.
OUR TEACHERS I THINK ONE OF THE
PLAYERS THAT'S A REALLY LOST IS
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY THE
COMMUNITY DOESN'T KNOW WHO TO
BELIEVE OFTENTIMES.
ARE AND SO IT'S VERY SHIN AND
FELT MARK [inaudible]
ABOUT UNDER BUDGETS --
I REALLY DO THINK THAT THE
PROBLEM FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S
HAPPENING IN SEX CITY UNIFIED --
COULD BE ALLAYED.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO MODERNIZE --
THE WAY OUR TEACHER WORKFORCE IS
BEING --
FOLLOWED AND IDENTIFIED FOR THE
AREAS FOR IMPROVEMENT AND
DEFINITELY WANT --
TO APPRECIATE AND THE PROPOSAL
TO BUILD A COMPREHENSIVE
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM --
IT REALLY NEEDS TO HAVE A FOCUS
ON EQUITY SO THAT --
STUDENTS WITH THE GREATEST NEEDS
AND SYSTEMS THAT SUPPORT THEM
CAN REALLY BE IDENTIFIED AND WE
CAN TARGET ARE SCARCE RESOURCES
FOR THEM THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND
STAFF DEBORAH BROWN ON BEHALF OF
A CHILDREN NOW AND ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE US IF AN EQUITY COALITION
AS WITH PREVIOUS SPEAKERS WE TO
REALLY APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
A COMMITMENT AND AND STRONG
STANCE AROUND --
K. TWELVE EDUCATION AND AND
EARLY EDUCATION I'M IN
PARTICULAR THE COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE FUNDING --
FOR LCS I'LL SEE IF F. WILL ALSO
RECOGNIZING THE OTHER CHALLENGES
THAT DISTRICTS ARE FACING AS
THEY TRY TO SERVE THEIR STUDENTS
AND HELP SUPPORT THEIR STAFF SO
IT YOU KNOW AS WE LOOK AT THE
IMPACT OF PENSION COSTS AND
SCHOOLS.
SPECIAL EDUCATION --
AMONG OTHERS WE APPRECIATE THAT
AND ALSO THIS COMMITTEES --
ENGAGEMENT ON THOSE ISSUES TO
SEE IF WE CAN FIND WAYS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE PROVIDING THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED --
OTHER AREAS AGAIN ALSO SUPPORT
THAT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
THE BOND FUNDING AND AND AGAIN
THAT THAT LUNCH TILL DATA SYSTEM
I'M IS IS EXTREMELY SIGNIFICANT
TO THAT WE KNOW WHAT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RESOURCES WE ARE
PROVIDING --
ARE MAKING IMPROVEMENTS FOR OUR
AS STUDENTS IN AND AGAIN ALSO
APPRECIATE THAT THE COMMITMENT
HERE IN THAT CONVERSATION HERE
AROUND I'M LOOKING BEYOND JUST
JUST.
WHAT THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
MINIMUM GUARANTEES THAT IS
CRITICAL A TO MAKE SURE THAT
THESE AND THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING
OUR STUDENTS ON ON EARLY ADD
JUST AGAIN --
AT THE FACT THAT THE GOVERNOR
CAME OUT SO STRONG AND EARLY ON
IN THIS REALLY SHOULD THE M.
WHAT WE HOPE IS HIS DEDICATION
AND COMMITMENT TO THIS ISSUE AND
AND REALLY.
THE THE IDEA THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THAT THAT --
THE INFRASTRUCTURE SO THE WITH
THE WORK FORCE AND FACILITIES SO
CAN WE LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
WITH YOU ALL AND WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE'RE MAKING.
THE RIGHT AND SOUND INVESTMENTS
THAT SUPPORT OUR ALL OF OUR KIDS
THANK YOU.
A GOOD MORNING MUNCIE SALON KIA
ON BEHALF OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENT ADVOCATES FROM IRVINE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO EMPHASIZE
ON THE ANECDOTAL EXPERIENCES
THAT ARE DIRECTLY INFLUENCED BY
YOUR POLICIES.
SO IN MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE --
CLASS SIZES HAVE BEEN A BIG
ISSUE OUR SCHOOL AND OUR EIGHTY
COST SIZE RANGE FROM THIRTY NINE
TO FORTY STUDENTS AND AS YOU CAN
SEE THAT IS A VERY LARGE AMOUNT.
AND IN GENERAL WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A LOT OF OTHER STUDENTS
SERVICES THAT AREN'T PROPERLY
FUNDED FOR INCLUDING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND COUNCILLORS --
RECENTLY WE HAD A BIG TRAUMA AT
OUR SCHOOL AND WE DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH GUIDANCE COUNSELORS TO
ACCOUNT FOR THAT SITUATION.
AND IN ADDITION --
THE FUNDING FOR THIS WOULD BE IT --
GREATLY HELPED THROUGH --
CFF UNFORTUNATELY IRVINE IS
FACED WITH THE PROBLEM THAT THE
FORMULA --
IS ACTUALLY LEAVING SO UNDER
FUNDING DUE TO THE FACT THAT WE
DO NOT HELD UP ADEQUATE NUMBER
OF LOW INCOME AND ENGLISH
LEARNER STUDENTS AND DOES NOT
MEET THE PERCENTAGE THAT LEADS
TO ON THE PROPER CONCENTRATION
FUNDING THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN --
VERY BENEFICIAL FOR OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT SO WE ALSO LIKE TO
FOCUS ON THE FACT THAT --
PROBABLY NINETY EIGHT IS
DEFINITELY JUST THE MINIMUM AND
THOUGHT WE SHOULD NOT CONSIDER
THE CEILING.
OF WE WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE --
BETTER FUNDING IN THE FUTURE AND
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH YOU.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
GOOD MORNING SURE MEMBERS THERE
ARE SEE WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY WE WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE INVESTMENTS TO PLAN AND
BEGIN DEVELOPMENT OF A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM.
THAT FOLLOWS STUDENTS FROM EARLY
AT THROUGH THE WORK FORCE --
WITHOUT SUCH A SYSTEM WE REALLY
ARE UNABLE TO ANSWER CRITICAL.
QUESTIONS TO STUDENT PROGRESSION
AND OUTCOMES FOR INSTANCE WERE
CALIFORNIA'S HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES APPLYING TO AND
ENROLLING IN COLLEGE --
ONCE THEY'RE THERE HOW LONG DO
THEY TAKE TO COMPLETE AND HOW DO
THEY USE THEIR FINANCIAL AID --
SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONTINUED DISCUSSION ON THIS I
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU TO ENSURE
THAT A SYSTEM IS CENTRALIZED
INDEPENDENT.
AND THAT DATA IS TRANSPARENT
TRANSPARENT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION IT'S
A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY.
I KNOW THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
SPOKEN TO THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
AND I'LL JUST TAKE OFF A COUPLE
OF POINTS I WANTED TO MENTION TO
YOU TODAY.
FIRST OF ALL WE'RE EXTREMELY
ENCOURAGED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATION AND THIS
BEING HIS FIRST BUDGET AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
HIM FOR THE NEXT FEW YEARS.
AND WITH YOURSELVES ONE OF THE
THINGS I WANTED TO MENTION WAS A
LONGITUDINAL DATA SYSTEM THAT
WAS MENTIONED.
A LAKE --
ALREADY HAS A SYSTEM CONNECTING
OUR EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
DATA PROGRAMS TO K. TWELVE
SYSTEMS WITHIN THE COUNTY WE'VE
ALREADY TAKEN THAT CHALLENGE ON
SO WE REALLY WANT TO BE A PART
OF THE DISCUSSION.
ANOTHER THING WE'VE DONE IS
WE'VE CREATED AN EDUCATIONAL
PASSPORT SYSTEM FOR CHILDREN WHO
ARE FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH.
AND THAT ALLOWS ALL OF THE
EIGHTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO BE
ABLE TO OBTAIN RECORDS AND GET
INFORMATION ON STUDENTS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTY.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE'RE
VERY PROUD OF ESPECIALLY FOR THE
FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH WHO
ARE IN AND OUT OF OUR JUVENILE
HALLS JUVENILE CAMPS.
AND ALSO COMMUNITY DAY SCHOOL SO
WE THINK THAT THE A MILESTONE
FOR US AND WE'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH OTHERS ON THAT.
ANOTHER THING I'D LIKE TO POINT
OUT IS THE FIFTY FIVE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS.
OF MONEY FOR THE DEFERRED. ONE
THING --
THAT WE KNOW IS LAST YEAR LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION HAD NINETEEN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IDENTIFIED.
AS NEEDING ASSISTANCE --
THROUGH THE STATE WIDE SYSTEMS
OF SUPPORT AS A RESULT OF THE
INFORMATION ON THE STATE WIDE
DASHBOARD.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SO THAT WE
THINK THE FUNDING IS VERY
IMPORTANT THERE --
WE'VE SENT OUT STRIKE TEAMS WERE
WORKING VERY EARLY WITH SCHOOL
DISTRICTS --
IN ORDER TO GET THROUGH ALL OF
THE DISTRICTS THAT NEED
ASSISTANCE.
ANOTHER THING I'D ADD IS A LATE
CALL WAS THE FIRST ONE TO COME
UP WITH AN ELECTRONIC EL CAP
TOOL.
BECAUSE WE HAD EIGHTY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WE HAD TO JUMP OUT
THERE FIRST AND GET GOING SO A
LOT OF THAT WORK THAT WE DO IS --
STARTING IN ADVANCE OF DEADLINES
AND WORKING WITH OUR DISTRICTS
ALL YEAR LONG --
WE THINK HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL WE
WERE ABLE TO TRANSITION WITH THE
HELP OF THE DISTRICTS AND THEIR
LEADERSHIPS WE WERE ARE HELPFUL
IN TRANSITIONING SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OFF OF A
DIFFERENTIATED ASSISTANCE LIST.
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE PANEL I AM ALSO
WITH THE STUDENT ADVOCACY
PROGRAM AS SPECIFICALLY
REPRESENTING CHESS PLAYERS IN
IRVINE UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT PLAYING
CHESS INCREASES STUDENT
PERFORMANCES ON STANDARDIZED
TESTS AND I WOULD URGE THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR. TO
CONSIDERED CONSIDER THIS DURING
THE BUDGETARY PROCESS AS WELL AS
TO PASS SENATE CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION FORTY ONE AGAIN AS A
BILL IS INTACT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNINGMICHELLE MCCANN
UNDER WHAT ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION FOR ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FUNDING
COALITION --
I'M HERE TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
ATTENTION TO STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT YEARS
SO TIGHT --
THE FACT THAT WERE WERE HAVING A
CONVERSATION ABOUT STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES WE THINK IS REALLY
ENCOURAGING AND AND DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE HEARING FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
OUT LIKE MANY OF THE CONCERNS
RAISED BY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ESPECIALLY --
MEMBER MARTUCCI AND THE MEDINA
AND O'DONNELL --
WHAT WE THINK THERE IS A
DIFFERENT WAY TO PUT THESE FUNDS
OUT WE KNOW THAT THE NEED IS
STATEWIDE --
THAT IS WHY FOR YEARS WE HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR INCREASING FUNDING
AFTER THE EXISTING SPECIAL
EDUCATION FORMULA FOR STUDENTS
WITH DISABILITIES TO EQUALIZE
THOSE FUNDING RATES --
TO PROVIDE STATE FUNDS FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES --
AND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING FOR STUDENTS WITH THE
MOST SEVERE DISABILITIES WE HAVE
TO ADD NOTES THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES ZERO RESOURCES FOR
PRESCHOOLERS WITH DISABILITIES
SO THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR US
TO INVEST IN --
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE THAT THIS IS
PART OF THE CONVERSATION THIS
YEAR AND SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
IT.
GOOD MORNING CHRISTOPHER MIRACLE
FOR THE CALIFORNIA HEAD START
ASSOCIATION I JUST WANT TO WHAT
WE WELCOME THE INTEREST AND
SUPPORT --
FOR CALIFORNIA'S YOUNGEST
CITIZENS --
THREE SIMPLE POINTS --
I DEEPLY DEEPLY BELIEVE THAT
TEACHERS ARE THE ALPHA AND OMEGA
OF QUALITY IN ANY SYSTEM SO ARE
WE SUPPORT ALL THE INVESTMENTS
THAT ARE BEING PROPOSED. TO
SUPPORT TEACHERS SERVING
CHILDREN.
ZERO TO FIVE SECONDLY WE WHEN I
REALLY ENCOURAGE THE COMMITTEE
AND AND THE GOVERNOR.
TO LEVERAGE EVERYTHING THAT YOU
HAVE IT IS ALREADY WORKING IN
THE SYSTEM AND ARE MIXED
DELIVERY SYSTEM HAS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT KINDS F PROVIDERS --
WE WENT --
TO AND MAXIMIZE PARTICULARLY THE
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS AND THE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT COMES IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGH --
HEAD START AND THEN FINALLY.
PURSUING A BUDGET PROPOSALS THAT
ARE GOOD FOR EVERYONE AND TARGET
THE GREATEST NEED FIRST
INCLUDING THOSE AREAS IN THE
STATE WHERE THERE ARE SIMPLY NOT
ENOUGH SLOTS FOR CHILDREN.
ZERO TO THREE THANKS VERY MUCH
OKAY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IN
THANKS TO EVERYBODY FOR
PARTICIPATING TODAY AGAIN
TOMORROW WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THE
STEP TO HEARING ON HIGHER
EDUCATION INCLUDING COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
AND WE'LL SEE THE REST OF YOU
LATER ON THE SPRING THANK YOU